NUMBER FIVE WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COBRA NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE.
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN THE
LEMONADE IN ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE. THE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R.
I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOUR DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEES. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN THE
QUORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AT ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MUST BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS. AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS. WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
NOW TO BEGIN THE HEARING. OF
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM- DR
FRANCIS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THANK CENTER DRAWS OF HERE
SENATOR DORADO HERE SENATOR
WILL PRESENT SENATOR WILL
PRESENT CENTER CORTESE YOUR
SENATOR CORTEZ HE HERE SENATOR
NEWMAN. SENATOR NEWMAN HERE.
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED OKAY THE
CONSULTANT NOTED QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED TODAY'S
HEARING WILL BE DIVIDED INTO
TWO PARTS PART A WILL COVER THE
MAINTENANCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSALS FOR THE CDC ARE. THEN
WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
AND THEN WE WILL VOTE. WE WILL
HAVE BREAK FOR A THIRTY MINUTE
TO HAVE A CHANGE IN OUR-
CONSULTANTS. THEN WE WILL MOVE
TO PART B. WHICH WILL COVER
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES WITH THE
DMB CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY AND THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL. THEN WE WILL
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT ON PART B.
AND CONTINUE WITH VOTE. OF FOR
PART A WE HAVE PANELISTS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WILL PRESENT
ON THESE ITEMS LET'S NOW START.
OF WITH ISSUE ONE. AND THAT'S
THE VALLEY STATE PRISON BSP
ARSENIC AND MANGANESE REMOVAL
WATER TREATMENT PLANT- WE ASK
PLEASE- THAT YOU PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH
BACKGROUND AND THE NEED FOR
EACH PROPOSAL BROUGHT FORTH
TODAY OF WILL THE CDC ARE BE
PRESENTING. YES MANAGER. GOOD
MORNING- MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRIS LEAVE. AND I AM
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR CDC ARE
AS DISABILITY PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT FRANK.
I DON'T WANT IS FOR THE ARSENIC
AND MANGANESE REMOVAL WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS A PALLISTER
PRISON. AS CDCR CONCURS WITH
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO REJECT
WAS WITHOUT PREJUDICE AT THE
PROJECT'S DESIGN ACTIVITIES
HAVE BEEN DELAYED. AND LATE
DECEMBER CDCR BECAME AWARE OF
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN THE
COST ESTIMATE FOR THE PROJECT
AND THIS IS DELAYED- FINAL
APPROVAL OF PULMONARY PLANS AND
STATE CRISSCROSSED TRIGGERED
ADDITIONAL WORK YOU. ARE WHEN
EXAMINING THE SCHEDULE- WORKING
DRAWINGS ARE NOW ANTICIPATED TO
BE COMPLETED LATE IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. SO DELAYING THE
CONSTRUCTION CORPORATION BY A
YEAR AT THIS POINT ONLY
REPRESENTS A FEW MONTHS DELAYED
TWO OR- EXTENDED TIMELINE FOR.
THE PROJECT- IN THE MEANTIME P.
WILL TO BLAND WATER FROM THE
WELLS TO PROVIDE WATER SUPPLY
THAT IS SAFE FOR STAFF AND
INMATES AT THE S. P. AND THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FACILITY. OKAY SO WE NEED HERE
TO HEAR FROM FINANCE PLEASE.
FOR SPRING RENDON MERIT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE CONCUR
WITH CDCR I'M SORRY WE VERY
WELL COULD YOU SAY THAT AGAIN
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING- BRANDON
MERIT DEPARTMENT FINANCE WE
CONCUR WITH CDCR. OKAY AND THE
L. A- PLEASE. MORNING I KNOW
NEIL. LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO
AHEAD. WE DIDN'T RAISE ANY
CONCERNS ON THIS PROPOSAL- AND
NOR DO WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE PROPOSED AT REJECTION OF
TALK TO JESS. OKAY. EARN I HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS HERE- CAN
YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN OF THE ISSUE
WITH ARSENIC AND MANGANESE
AGAIN IN THE WELLS AND THE
REASON BEHIND THE EXTENDED
TIMELINE CAN YOU. SUMMARIZE IT
AGAIN. SURE OKAY- THE PROJECT
IS NECESSARY BECAUSE OF THE
TREND OF INCREASING ARSENIC AND
MANGANESE LEVELS IN THE
GROUNDWATER OF THOSE LEVELS
VERY AND- DIFFERENT WELLS AND
CURRENTLY- SAFE DRINKING WATER
IS ABLE TO BE PROVIDED BY
PLANTING- THE SOURCE WATER FROM
THE DIFFERENT WELLS- AS I SAY-
I MENTIONED EARLIER- THE- COST
ESTIMATE FOR THE PROJECT THAT-
THE CONCLUSION OF LUNAR PLANS
WAS. QUITE A BIT HIGHER THAN
ANTICIPATED- THEREFORE THAT
TRIGGERED AN ADDITIONAL REVIEW
EXTENDING THE TIMELINE FOR.
LANDS AND SUBSEQUENTLY AT THE
START OF WORKING DRAWINGS- THAT
THAT'S THE REASON FOR THE
EXTENT I'M ONE. OKAY I WAS
CONCERNED THAT EXTENDING THE
TIMELINE FURTHER WOULD ENDANGER
THE INCARCERATED MEN AND WOMEN
AT THE S. P. AND C. C. W. F. SO
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THEY HAVE SAFE WATER
WHILE THIS TIME LINE IS
EXTENDED- AS I ALSO MENTIONED-
THE- EXTENDED TIMELINE REALLY
ONLY REPRESENTS A COUPLE OF
MONTHS- BECAUSE OF THE TIMING
OF THE- ANTICIPATED A
CONCLUSION OF WORKING DRAWINGS
WHICH IS NOW EXPECTED TO BE
LATE IN THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR-
SO- IN THE IN THE MEANTIME- THE
WATER WILL BE CONTINUE TO PLAN
TO PROVIDE A SAFE WATER
SUPPLIES TO THE INSTITUTION.
OKAY THANK YOU- COLLEAGUES. YES
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU
MEDICARE SO THERE'S AN A LA A
REPORT- THAT INDICATES THERE
BELIEVE THAT UP TO FIVE PRISONS
COULD BE CLOSED- IS VSP ONE OF
THOSE PRISON IS LIKELY TO BE ON
THAT LIST. THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. WOULD YOU
LIKE US TO ADDRESS THAT
QUESTION CENTER NEWMAN. I GUESS
YOU COULD START FIRST NAME LIKE
HERE FROM CITIES YOUR SHORT I
GUESS. THE CONCERN IS IF THE
IF- THIS WINDS UP. IF IT IS
TRUE THAT WE CAN CLOSE FIVE
PRISONS AND THIS WERE ONE OF
THOSE PERSPECTIVE FIVE- THE
THAT WOULD PREEMPT THE NEED FOR
THIS PROJECT OBVIOUSLY- SO WE-
AS AS YOU INDICATED WE HAVE AN
SSN BASED ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
POPULATION PROJECTIONS. AT THE
STATE COULD CLOSE FIVE PRISONS
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS ONE OF
THAT THE STATE HAS ALREADY
PLANNED TO CLOSE THE DOOR
VOCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
THAT'S ONE OF THOSE PRISONS
THAT LEAVES FOR LEFT IT
APARTMENT HASN'T- INDICATED
WHAT PRISON IT WILL CLOSE- IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
WHICH IT PLANS IT HAS INDICATED
IT WILL CLOSE ONE PRISON BEYOND
THAT THAT DEPARTMENT HASN'T
INDICATED ANY OTHER- OR
COMMITTED TO ANY FURTHER PRISON
CLOSURES- HOWEVER BASED ON OUR
INITIAL- ASSESSMENT. WE THINK
THAT THE CALIFORNIA
REHABILITATION CENTER IN NORCO.
THAT CALIFORNIA MEN'S COLONY IN
SAN LUIS OBISPO SAN QUENTIN
STATE PRISON AND CORRECTIONAL
TRAINING FACILITY IN SOLEDAD
ALL APPEAR TO BE. REASONABLE
CANDIDATES FORECLOSURE GIVEN
THEIR HIGH INFRASTRUCTURE COST-
AND RELATIVELY HIGH OPERATIONAL
COSTS IN COMPARISON TO THEIR IN
THE CAPACITY. CREATURE THAT'S
ARE THERE AND THEN BY INFERENCE
THEN THE OBVIOUS P. THAT IS DUE
FOR THIS INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADE
WOULD NOT BE ON THAT LIST AND
THEIR FOURTH THIS IS A
REASONABLE EXPENSE LOOKING
FORWARD. RIGHT AS WE DON'T IN
OUR REVIEW WE HAVEN'T
IDENTIFIED VALLEY STATE PRISON
AS A LIKELY CANDIDATE FOR
CLOSURE- ALTHOUGH AS YOU'LL
HEAR ME DISCUSS LATER IN ONE OF
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE-
ADMINISTRATION COME FORWARD
WITH A LIST OF LIKELY. AG
PRISONS FOR CLOSURE FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THIS IMPLEMENTING
OUR RECOMMENDATION RELATED TO
D. AS- PROPOSED AGGREGATION FOR
SPECIAL REPAIR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SO TO THE EXTENT
THE INITIATION DID. INCLUDE
THAT PRISON AS A- A LIKELY
CANDIDATE THAT IT BELIEVES-
WOULD MAKE SENSE FOR CLOSURE
THEN OF COURSE WE WOULD HAVE.
CONCERNS WITH THIS CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROPOSAL GOING FORWARD
FISH AT THAT SO I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT A PRISON WHERE THE WATER
IS. A SUSPECT QUALITY MIGHT BE.
CONSIDERED AT SOME POINT FOR
THAT LIST. THANK YOU. SECRETARY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST
GOING BACK TO- PICTURES
QUESTION ABOUT. SO THE QUALITY
OF THE WATER OR WRIST THE
INMATES OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS MMHM WELL THE PROJECTS
BEING- RECALCULATED REBUILD-
WHAT CAN YOU JUST. TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF A DEEPER DIVE
WITH US IN TERMS OF EXPLAINING
WHY THIS IS NOT A RISK I HEARD
OF THE TERM- YOU KNOW THE-
THAT'LL BE A BLENDED APPROACH
IN THE MEANTIME- IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE TALKING I DON'T WANT TO
PUT WORDS IN ANYONE'S MOUTH OR
MY OWN MIND IS THAT. THE IDEA
THAT YOU'RE- DILUTING THE- THE
ARSENIC AND MANGANESE LEVELS BY
BY IMPORTING. A WATER- TOOK TO
BLEND WITH THE WELL WATER IN.
AND DEPENDING ON THE ANSWER
THAT QUESTION I GUESS THE FAULT
QUESTIONS WOULD BE. YOU KNOW
WHY NOT JUST IMPORT WATER INTO
INTO INTO THE TANKS OF THE
WORLD'S WOULD NORMALLY FEED ON
INTERFACES OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
SOME COST TO THAT BUT- TO
ELIMINATE THE INMATE RISK. YEAH
SURE THANK YOU. I THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION- SO THERE IS NO
EXTERNAL WATER SOURCE- OR- FEES
FOR THE WATER SUPPLY SO WHAT
THE SITUATION WE HAVE IS THERE
ARE SEVERAL WELLS SOME OF WHICH
HAVE- THAT ARSENIC LEVELS THAT
EXCEED. DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS BUT OTHERS THAT DO
NOT SEEN BY BLENDING THEM
TOGETHER OR WE CAN STAY UNDER-
THE- THE DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS FOR ARSENIC AND
MANGANESE- I JUST NEED IT
BECAUSE WE SEE- A TRANS- IN ALL
THE WELLS INCREASING LEVELS.
ARE BUT WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
THAT THERE WOULD BE ANY PROBLEM
WITH LANDING OVER THE
FORECASTED- PROJECT TIMELINE-
DESERT CIRCLING BACK- TO ELYAS-
COMMENTS- I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
COMMITTED SAID THE CLOSURE OF
TWO PRESENTS AND NOTHING BEYOND
THAT AT THIS TIME- AND I HAVE.
AND ALSO I WOULD NOTE THAT THIS
WATER TREATMENT PLANTS A
SERVICE BOTH ABOUT THE STATE
PRISON AND THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY-
SO- THE PRICE WOULD BE NEEDED
UNLESS BOTH PERSONS. AND THAT'S
VERY UNLIKELY SINCE THIS CAL
WOMEN'S IS- ONE OF A FEW
WOMEN'S PRISON FIFTH. THANK YOU
AND APPRECIATE YOU- FOLLOWING
UP ON THE EARLIER QUESTIONS AS
WELL. IT IS ONE ONE LAST
QUESTION WHAT WHAT'S THE TOTAL
GALLONS USED PER DAY- TO SUPPLY
THE FACILITY. DON'T HAVE- LET
ME LET ME LET ME TAKE A SHORT
CUT WAY OF DEALING DEALING WITH
WHAT I'M GETTING AT I KNOW YOU
SAID THAT THERE'S NO ALTERNATE
SOURCE WATER WITH I MEAN
THERE'S ALWAYS AN ALTERNATIVE
SOURCE WATER WHICH IS TAKING%
BRINGING IT IN- THERE'S RASHES
AND FACILITIES ALL OVER OF MY
DISTRICT IN IN THE HILLS OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY THAT DEPEND
UPON A PERCENT ON IMPORTED
WATER LIKE THAT- AND I WAS JUST
TRYING TO GET AN IDEA AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S-
COMPLETELY INFEASIBLE
IMPRACTICABLE I GUESS IN TERMS
OF THE TOTAL USAGE. A PER DAY-
UP. NORTH THAT WAS EVEN
COMPARED YOU KNOW TO THE
SPLENDID APPROACH AS AS AN
ALTERNATIVE. AND ALLOW ME SAY I
AM NOT I THINK THE BLENDED
APPROACH IS PROBABLY A GOOD
IDEA I'M JUST I'M JUST CURIOUS
ENOUGH AT THIS POINT TO. ASK
THE QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT YOU COULD BE JUST. SAID HEY
FOR THE NEXT TWO MONTHS WE'LL
JUST. WE'LL JUST IMPORT THE
WATER. I DON'T HAVE THIS
SPECIFIC- VOLUME INFORMATION AT
THE- TOOK MY- FINGERS RIGHT
NOW- HOWEVER AS CERTAINLY
IMPORTING WATER FOR USE WOULD
BE A- MORE EXPENSIVE. A
TEMPORARY. SOLUTION WE WILL OF
COURSE CONTINUE TO MONITOR THAT
THE LEVELS OF THESE
CONSTITUENTS AND THE WATER. AND
IF NECESSARY WE WOULD MOVE TO
SOME ALTERNATIVE APPROACH TO
PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING WATER
FOR- SILVA. YES IT WILL BE JUST
SAY OF THEM. RIGHT UNDER THAT
THE MOST. OUR WATER HAS SOME OF
ARSENIC IN IT I DON'T KNOW BUT
MAINLY SO- YOU KNOW IT'S ON
THAT BASIS- SUPPORTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS- COLLEAGUES-
THE IDEA THAT- IT'S RARE TO SEE.
BUT YOU KNOW ZERO CONTENT- YOU
KNOW IT AIN'T IN ANY SYSTEM SO
IF YOU CAN BRING IT DOWN BY
BLAMING THEM A PERSON BECAUSE
THAT PROBABLY IS THE BEST
APPROACH BUT AS I SAID I WAS
JUST CURIOUS AS TO. AS TO THAT
OTHER ALTERNATIVE. THANK YOU.
OKAY WE WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
THE- PATIENT YEAH. YOUR THROUGH
THE CHERRY IT WOULD BE NICE TO
HAVE AT THIS POINT TO SATISFY
MY CURIOSITY IF NOTHING ELSE IF
IT'S NOT TOO HARD TO DIG UP
THANK YOU- NO MORE QUESTIONS
THE- RECOMMENDATION ON THIS IS
TO REJECT WITHOUT. PREJUDICE
AND WE CAN MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO.
WHICH I THINK WILL CONTINUE TO
RAISE WHAT A CENTER NEWMAN'S A
CONCERNS ARE AT SO WE COULD GET
DEEPER ON THAT ON THAT- ON THIS
ISSUE- SO COULD WE HAVE CDC ARE
PRESENT PLEASE. I THANK THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- I I'LL NOTE
THAT- THERE ARE FOUR SEPARATE-
PROPOSALS IN THIS ITEM- WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO PRESENTS ALL
FOUR AND THEN TAKE QUESTIONS OR
DO YOU WANT ME TO PAUSE BETWEEN
EACH ONE. OF YOU WANT TO JUST
TAKE ALL FOUR WE COULD GET THE
COMPLETE PICTURE. OKAY THANK
THANK YOU- THE FIRST. THE FIRST
ITEM IS A REAPPROPRIATION OF
FIFTY FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION-
GENERAL FUND- THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY APPROPRIATED AND
THAT TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
FOR THE FIRE ALARM FIRE
SUPPRESSION REPAIR. PROJECTS AT
MULE CREEK STATE PRISON RICHARD
J. DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY. AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRISON SACRAMENTO. WITH
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO EXTEND
THE EXPENDITURE AND CONGRESS.
APPROVED JAN THIRTY TWENTY
TWENTY OR- AT THE TIMELINE FOR
ESTABLISHING PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA WHICH SETS FORTH THE
TECHNICAL REQUIREMENTS FOR A
FIRM. TO COMPLETE AT DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF THE THUMB. I
WAS EXTENDED TENTH FULLY
DOCUMENTED PROJECT SCOPE. AND
TO ALLOW SUFFICIENT TIME FOR
REVIEW SUBMITTALS TO THE OFFICE
OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL. AT
THE NOTICE A BIT TO PROCEED TO
THE SELECTED DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACTOR IS ANTICIPATED AND
ALL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WITH
THE PROJECT DURATION OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS. ARE THERE FOR PROJECT
COMPLETION IS ANTICIPATED AND
FALL TWENTY TWENTY THREE- THIS
ACTION IS NECESSARY TO- HAVE
THE- FUNDS AVAILABLE TO PROCEED
THROUGH THE- DESIGN. BUILD
PHASE OF THE PROJECT. AT THE
NEXT IS FOR HEALTH OF HIS
REPIR AT THE HELP READ. CENTER
IT'S FOR SIX POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
MAKE HEALTH CARE FACILITY
REPAIRS AT THE CALIFORNIA
REHABILITATION CENTER THIS IS A
RECENT MIDDLE OF THE REQUEST
WAS WITHDRAWN AT LAST YEAR'S
MAY REVISION. I TRICKS WILL
MAKE NUMEROUS REPAIRS THAT'S
YOUR SEATS TO MAKE MEDICAL
SPACES SAFE AND FUNCTIONAL
INCLUDING REPLACING DAMAGED
FLOORING WALLS CASE WORK IN
DOORS. IN ADDITION THE PROJECT
WILL REPLACE SEVERAL EXISTING
MEDICAL DISTRIBUTION WHEN DOES
IT PROTECT ALL MEDICATION
DISTRIBUTION MENDOZA LONGCASE
WORKPLACE FANS AND INSTALLATION
OF HANDWASHING THINGS. THIS
FACILITY WAS NOT INCLUDED IN
THE HEALTH CARE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM- BECAUSE
THAT TWENTY TWELVE BLUEPRINTS
ANTICIPATED IT WOULD CLOSE IN
THE NEAR FUTURE HOWEVER AT THIS
TIME FINISAR INTENDS TO
CONTINUE OPERATIONS IT'S HERE'S
THE- NEEDS REPAIRS ARE NEEDED
TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE MEDICAL
SPACE TO SERVE THE POPULATION I
WAS THERE. I REPAIRS ARE
ANTICIPATED TO BEGIN IN SPRING
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO AFTER
DESIGN IS COMPLETED AND REPAIRS
ARE ANTICIPATED TO BE COMPLETED
OVER A NINETEEN MONTH PERIOD.
AFTER DESIGN IS COMPLETE- WITH
A PROJECT COMPLETION AND- THE
FALL POINTS TWENTY TWENTY. FIVE
THE THIRD REQUEST IN THIS ITEM
FOR ONE TIME DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
ADDRESS DID YOU SEE OUR IS
DEPARTMENT AND- AT THE REQUEST
REQUESTED ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION
ALLOWS CITIES HERE TO DEVELOP
AND EXECUTE. PLANS SPECIAL
RIPARIAN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS TO ADDRESS YOU SEE R.
AS- A SPECIAL KERN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG. AND TO
ACHIEVE MADE MAJOR BUILDING AND
SITE WIDE IFRASTRUCTURE REPAIR
SYSTEM REPLACEMENT. PROJECTS
ARE PRIORITIZED AT ADDRESS
SEVERAL TYPES OF CONDITIONS
WHICH IS REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS THE CORRECT
BAYERN'S LIFE SAFETY ISSUES. TO
REPAIR REPLACE SYSTEMS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEED IS THE ONLY
OPERATIONAL FOR TO ADDRESS SITE
WIDE SECURITY ISSUES.
DESCRIPTION OF PROJECT IS IN
ADDITION TO EXISTING PROJECTS
UNDERNEATH THAT NORMALLY OCCUR
EACH FISCAL YEAR AND OUR TRUST
EUROCITY SERVICE BASED NETWORK
ALLOCATION TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE FOURTH
PROPOSAL- AND- THIS ITEM IS FOR
REPLACEMENT- IT'S FOR
REPLACEMENT OF THE ROOF A
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
SACRAMENTO WHICH CONSIST I'M
SORRY- WITH THE REPLACEMENT IS
FOR MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE
REPLACEMENT OF THE- BRUCE IT'S
HOW CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON LOS
ANGELES- AND CONSISTS OF ONE
MILLION DOLLARS JOURNAL FINDS
FOR DESIGN AND TWENTY TWO AND
THIRTY TWO POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS UP OR CONSTRUCTION.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
REPLACEMENT IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE OF THE DETERIORATING
CONDITIONS OF EXISTING ROOMS
THAT SEVERELY IMPACT HOUSING
CONDITIONS AN INMATE ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS. I WITH THIS YEAR'S
PROPOSALS- CDCR HAS REEVALUATED
THE PHASE PLANNED FOR STATE
WHAT ROOF REPLACEMENTS ARE
RESULTING IN A RECORDED STATION
UP THE REMAINING FACILITY.
SPECIFICALLY OF THE SAUDIS WITH
HIGH RISK MEDICAL AND AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITIES ACT MISSIONS
WERE GIVEN HIGHER PRIORITY AS
THOSE INMATES. ARE SUSCEPTIBLE
TO HARM TO THE LEAKY ROOFS IN
HOUSING PROGRAM LOCATION. OKAY.
C. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
JUSTIN EDELMAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
WANTED TO RESPOND- L. A. AS
RECOMMENDATIONS ON SOME OF
THESE PROPOSALS FOR THE HEALTH
CARE FACILITY REPAIRS IT'S HERE
SEE THE L. A. RECOMMENDED-
REJECTION OF THE PROPOSAL
UNLESS THE ADMINISTRATION CAN
PROVIDE A LONG TERM PLAN FOR
THE FACILITY THIS IS
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE REPAIRS
WILL BE COMPLETED SUFFICIENTLY
IN ADVANCE OF ANY. POTENTIAL
OUR FUTURE CLOSER DATE. AND
THERE ARE WE WANT WE WANT TO
KNOW THAT THEIR EXISTING- OR
PRESSURES IT EGGS NEED TO BE
CAN TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION-
SPECIFICALLY IN TWENTY TWELVE
AT CCR IMPLEMENTED THE
HEALTHCARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM TO IMPROVE TREATMENT
AND CLINICAL SPACE ACROSS ALL
OF ITS INSTITUTIONS FOR HEALTH
CARE NEEDS- HOWEVER BACK MAN IN
TWENTY TWELVE THERE WAS
ANTICIPATED CLOSURE OF CRC SO
THEY HECTIC PROJECT AS IT'S
KNOWN IS THAT WAS NEVER
IMPLEMENTED IT'S YOUR SEATS.
AND SO THEY ARE C. HAS BEEN
OPERATING- WITHOUT
IMPLEMENTATION OF A HECTIC
PROJECT AND THAT'S RESULTED IN
A MEDICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE
FACILITY IT IS INCONSISTENT
WITH SIMILAR SITUATIONS IN
OTHER PRISONS. WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE REQUESTING BE AT SIX
TWENTY MILLION HERE CHECK KIND
OF REPAIR AND REFINED SOME OF
THESE- IT'S SEVENTIES WHICH
APPROACHING SEVENTY FIVE YEARS
IN AGE. THAT THAT THEY'RE UP TO
THAT MEDICAL STANDARDS FOR THE
FEDERAL RECEIVERSHIP- BETTER
INDICATING OTHER INSTITUTIONS-
BAY AREA ALSO RECOMMENDED. THAT
REJECTING OR PROHIBITING CCR
FROM SPENDING- DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDS AT PRISONS
THAT ARE LIKELY OR STRONG
CANDIDATES FOR CLOSURE. AND WE
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT.
IDENTIFYING PRISONS FOR CLOSURE
IS A VERY COMPLICATED AND
SENSITIVE ISSUE ON THEIR MANY
FACTORS BEYOND JUST
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT GO
INTO. WHICH PRESENTS THE
CLOTHES AND HOW TO IDENTIFY
THOSE PRISONS- IT INCLUDES
THINGS LIKE THAT POPULATION
MISSIONS- STAFFING LEVELS WE
HAVE BILL BELICHICK OF PROGRAM
OPPORTUNITIES AT THESE
INSTITUTIONS. HAS COVERED HAS
DEMONSTRATED WE ALSO NEED TO
BEAR IN MIND THE INSTITUTIONS
NEED A CERTAIN LEVEL SPACE TO
PREVENT- AIRBORNE PATHOGENS
FROM BEING EASILY SPREAD- WHICH
IS AGAIN VERY IMPORTANT FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND FOR COURT
CONSIDERATIONS. GOING FORWARD.
AND SO. REALLY I PRISONS ARE
LIKE TO CLOSE ALSO OPERATIONAL.
FOR CD START THREE ISSUES WITH
STAFFING- IN MAINTAINING
INSTITUTIONS FOR THE NEED UNTIL
THEY WILL CLOSE. SO IT'S A
REALLY COMPLICATED ISSUE AND
IDENTIFYING PRISONS FOR CLOSURE
IS A PATH WE DON'T WANT TO
START DOWN INTO WERE RELATIVELY
CERTAIN THAT CAN BE COMPLETED-
AND AGAIN BRINGING BACK TO THE
POINT OF. HAVING A BIT BECAUSE
PREVIOUSLY IN TWENTY TWELVE IT
WAS. CONSIDERED FOR POSSIBLE
CLOSURE SO WE SET OURSELVES UP
FOR FUTURE COSTS- THAT ARE VERY
DIFFICULT TO PREDICT IN THE
CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCES. OKAY AND
BEFORE WE MOVE ON ON THAT
ISSUE- BELIAU. COMMENTS PLEASE
THIS IS CAITLIN O'NEILL WITH
THE L. A. L. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- COMMITTEE STAFF HAS
ASKED ME TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON AT SHARES
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AND THEN I
WILL GET MY RECORD OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THAT. I
THEIR PROPOSALS IN THIS ITEM. I
TO MOVING INTO THAT BACKGROUND
I'VE BEEN A TALK ABOUT TWO MAIN
TYPES OF INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
AND THEN PROVIDE SEND A BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE THAT WAS
ADOPTED BY THE LEGISLATURE WITH
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT. I
SPECIAL REPAIR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE REFERS TO A
CATEGORY OF PROJECTS THAT ARE-
SENSUALLY REQUIRED TO BRING IN
EXISTING. ASSETS SUCH AS A
BUILDING ORA BOILER ELECTRICAL
SYSTEM FROM A SUB PAR OR FAILED
STATE PATH TO ANY NEEDED
SERVICE LEVEL THAT THEY'RE
BIGGER THAN YOUR NORMAL AND
PROGRESS STANDARD ROUTINE
PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE ARE
SIMPLE FOR REPLACEMENT OF A
PARK. HE SIERRA AND BACKLOG- OF
ABOUT A MILLION DOLLARS IN
SPECIAL REPAIR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THROUGHOUT ITS
PRISONS- VOTER CAN'T FIX PACKS
OF THE ACTUAL NEED IS CLOSER TO
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS. ADD
THE DEPARTMENT NOTE THE BASE
THE PURPOSE LEASE OKAY TO BASE
BUDGET INCLUDES SIX MILLION FOR
THIS PURPOSE BUT IN RECENT
YEARS IT'S RECEIVE VARIOUS ONE
TIME AUGMENTATION SUCH AS- FOR
ROOF REPLACEMENTS- CAPITAL
OUTLAY AND THE OTHER. TYPE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT I
WANTED TO GIVE A BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON- IS ACCUSED YOU
CAN THINK OF IS CREATING A NEW
ASSET AS OPPOSED TO REPAIRED
REPAIRING OR REPLACING
SOMETHING THAT'S EXISTING. AND
THERE ISN'T A SIMILAR BACKLOG
TRACKING SYSTEM FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY AS THERE IS FOR
DIFFERENT MAINTENANCE SPECIAL
REPAIRS- HOWEVER THAT IT
ADMINISTRATION FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN- INDICATES
THAT. IT PLANS TO REQUEST
FUNDING OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS FOR. ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS AT ITS
FACILITIES- ALTHOUGH A RECENT
STUDY AND IN DEPTH STUDY BY AN
EXTERNAL CONTRACTOR OF THE
STATE'S TWELVE OLDEST PRISONS-
SUGGESTS THAT THE NEED IS
ACTUALLY MUCH LARGER. AND I CAN
STILL RECOMMENDED OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BACK CAPITAL
OUTLAY AND SPECIAL REPAIR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
MOSTLY CAPITAL OUTLAY. AT YES
THOSE TWELVE PRISON LOANS
TOTALING. SIGNIFICANT
INFRASTRUCTURE NEED THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED
SUPPLEMENTAL RECORDING LANGUAGE
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
ACT DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT TO
REPORT. BY JANUARY TENTH OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO A- A LIST OF
PROJECTS ARE IDENTIFYING A LIST
OF PROJECTS ARE LIKELY TO BE
NEEDED OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
TO KEEP ITS PRISONS OPERATIONAL
AND EITHER INDEFINITELY OR
UNTIL THEY'RE CLOSED- AND TO
THE LANGUAGE ALSO DIRECTS THE
DEPARTMENT TO PRIORITIZE THAT
LIST BASED ON CERTAIN CRITERIA.
HOWEVER THE DEPARTMENT HAS
INDICATED THAT IT DOESN'T PLAN
TO FULLY COMPLY WITH THIS
LANGUAGE I'M NOT TOO CONCERNED
BECAUSE A LACK OF A LONG TERM
PLAN MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATURE TO
EVALUATE. AND THE GOVERNOR TO
FOR STRUCTURE PROPOSALS
MOREOVER IF THE STATE CONTINUES
TO FUND INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
WITHOUT A LONG VIEW IT RISKS
ONE UNNECESSARILY SPENDING
MONEY ON SUCH AS ON PROJECTS-
THAT OUR LIVES LATER AFTER
SILLY IS THAT ARE LATER EITHER
CLOSED OR REBUILD MORE
THOROUGHLY. TO GET REST MISSING
OPPORTUNITIES TO ACHIEVE
OPERATIONAL BENEFITS OR REDUCED
OPERATIONAL COSTS SUCH AS BY
RELOCATING FACILITIES OR BEEN
DESIGNING THEM. AND THREE AT
RISK FAILING TO SUFFICIENTLY
ADDRESS- MITIGATE THE RISK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE FAILURE WHICH
CAN HAVE SIGNIFICANT COST AND
SAFETY IMPLICATIONS. AND UNLESS
YOU'RE LIKE ME TO PIES FOR ANY
QUESTIONS BUT I WILL MOVE ON TO
GET OUR RECOMMENDATIONS. WHAT
DID YOU FINISH WITH YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN WE
COULD START WITH OUR QUESTIONS-
SO- WE RECOMMENDATIONS ON TWO
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS IN
THIS ITEM. FIRST IS A FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR REQUESTED
DOCUMENTATION TO THE DEPARTMENT
SPACE SPECIAL REPAIR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND BUDGET GIVEN
THE SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS IN THE STATE PRISON
SYSTEM WE RECOMMEND APPROVING
IT BUT WE RECOMMEND RESTRICTING
THE USAGE OF THE FUNDS- SO THAT
THEY CANNOT BE SPENT ON PRISONS
LIKELY TO BE CLOSED IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. AND THAT'S BECAUSE AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THIS STATE IS
PLAIN CLOTHES IN NINETEEN
PRISON IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND COULD WE THINK
CLOTHES- AROUND THREE
ADDITIONAL PRISONS- AND THESE
DEFERRED SPECIAL CARE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS CAN TAKE A
COUPLE YEARS TO COMPLETE SO
IT'S VERY POSSIBLE THAT THE
STATE WOULD BE COMPLETING THE
REPAIR. AROUND THE TIME THAT
THE PRISON IS CLOSE WHICH WOULD
NOT BE COST EFFECTIVE. SO WHAT
WE RECOMMEND APPROVING BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE RESTRICTING CDC
ARE FROM SPENDING THE FUNDS AB
PRISONS LIKELY FOR TO BE CLOSED
TO FACILITATE THAT WE THINK
THAT THAT MINISTRATION SHOULD
PROVIDE A LIST OF PRISONS TO BE
CLOSED- ABSENT THAT BASED ON
OUR INITIAL REVIEW AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED- FOR PRISONS. THAT
WE THINK ARE STRONG CANDIDATES.
AND THEN THE SECOND. THAT WE
HAVE A RECOMMENDATION ON IS
THE- HEALTHCARE FACILITY
REPAIRS AT THE CALIFORNIA REAL.
ELEVATION CENTER. A SIMILAR
ANALYSIS APPLIES HERE AND IT
THE PROPOSAL THAT EXCUSE ME TO
PRISON SEEMS TO BE A STRONG
CANDIDATE FOR CLOSURE IN FACT
ADMINISTRATION ITSELF IS
PROPOSED FOR CLOSURE. IN THE
PAST- IF THE PROJECT. THE
PROJECT WHERE THAT. VERY
POSSIBLY BE COMPLETED AROUND
THE TIME THAT THE PRISON IS
BEING CLOSED AND AGAIN I WOULD
NOT BE COST EFFECTIVE SO UNLESS
THAT ADMINISTRATION CAN PROVIDE
A LONG TERM PLAN FOR THIS
PRISON THAT DEMONSTRATES THAT
THE FACILITY OR EXCUSE ME THAT
THE PROJECT WOULD BE COMPLETED
IN ADVANCE OF A POTENTIAL
CLOSURE DATE- WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING. THIS PROPOSAL AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DOES GIVE THAT IT COULD
REALLOCATE THE FUNDS TO.
ADDRESS HIGH PRIORITY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AT
OTHER PRISONS THAT ARE NOT
LIKELY TO BE CLOSED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I THINK
THIS GOES TO WHAT SENATOR
NEWMAN RAISED A LITTLE WHILE
AGO WHICH IS WHY IS IT THAT WE
CANNOT GET. THIS ARM
PRIORITIZATION ALL LONG TERM
PRIVATIZATION- PLAN- THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE OF PAST
RESTORATIONS INCLUDED
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
THAT THE DEPARTMENT COULD
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
LONG TERM PRIORITIZATION OVER
PROJECTS EXLEY EXCEEDING FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. SO I WOULD
LIKE FOR YOU ALL TO PLEASE GIVE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE AN UPDATE ON
THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS
TOWARDS SATISFYING THE SRO
REPORT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
I'VE HEARD THAT THE CDC ARE
SAID THAT THEY WOULD NOT COMPLY
WITH PARTS OR ALL OF THE S. R.
L. R. L. FROM THE LEGISLATURE
AND IT'S QUITE DISTURBING- TO
HEAR THAT RATHER THAN HERE'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING THIS IS AS FAR
AS WE'VE GOTTEN. SOMETHING TO
SHOW IS THAT YOU ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT DOING IT OR IF YOU'RE NOT
SERIOUS ABOUT DOING THAT THEN
WE SHOULD KNOW AND WE'LL FIGURE
OUT SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE
SHOULD DO BUT- I THINK IT'S ANA
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE THIS AS
THE CONTEXT FOR THE OUR
REQUESTS THAT ARE BEING MADE
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE ANSWERS TO
THE LONG TERM OTHERWISE WERE
REALLY WASTING AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY- SO I WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO HEAR FROM. OF
THE CDC ARE WHY YOU WON'T
COMPLY WITH UP I BELIEVE WHAT
IS YOUR DUTY. TO GIVE US THIS
OUR PLAN. I THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION FROM CBC ARE IS
COMMITTED TO SHARING AVAILABLE
INFORMATION ABOUT ITS
FACILITIES CONDITION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. OTHER
SYSTEMS INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT NEEDS ARE
SIGNIFICANT- WITH MORE THAN A
BILLION DOLLARS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS IDENTIFIED
STATE WIDE. CDC I RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO MAKE THE BEST POSSIBLE
DECISIONS REGARDING
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT. AS
WITH ALL FACILITIES IN CAPITAL
PROGRAM CITY HERE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE INFORMATION IS
PROVIDED AS A POINT IN TIME. AS
NEW INFORMATION BECOMES
AVAILABLE ABOUT THE SILICON%
VISION OR POLICY DIRECTION
TENCEL PROJECTS WILL USE.
ANYTHING IS LANDS. THE TEN YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE DOCUMENT AS
PROPOSED AND B. S. R. L.
EXPANDS BEYOND HOW THE STATE
CURRENTLY PLANS FOR ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. THE
CURRENT PROCESS THE FIVE YEAR
PLANNING FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY
NEEDS. FOLLOWED BY CDCR AND
OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS WITH
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROGRAMS IN
STRAIGHT SETS CDCR HAS MANY
HIGH PRIORITY INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS BEYOND THOSE FOR WHICH
FUNDING IS INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. EVEN IN THE BEST A
BUDGET CIRCUMSTANCES. AS NOTED
MORE THAN A BILLION DOLLARS OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
HAVEBEEN IDENTIFIED STATEWIDE.
WHICH FAR EXCEEDS AVAILABLE
FUNDING. FROM THAT LIST OR
BASED ON OTHER EMERGENCY NEEDS
CDC ARE ONLY PROCEEDS WITH THE
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION. OF THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY PROJECTS
WITHIN AVAILABLE RESOURCES.
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SAUDIS IS
NOT PERFECT AND CHANGES OVER
TIME IT IS NOT POSSIBLE TO
IDENTIFY EVERY PROJECT THAT
WILL BE NEEDED OVER TEN YEAR
WINDOW. INTENDING TO DO SO
WOULD DIVERT RESOURCES NEEDED
TO ADDRESS CURRENT. DRIVERS FOR
PRIORITIZING PROJECTS COMPLEX
MULTIFACTORIAL. PROJECTS
ADDRESS A WIDE GAMUT OF NEEDS
WHETHER IT IS ADDRESSING ASSET
RENEWAL PROVIDING ADEQUATE
SPACE FOR PROGRAMMING. MEDICAL
MENTAL HEALTH CARE DRESSING
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
CORRECTING OPERATIONAL ISSUES
REPORTING COSTS THROUGH
MODIFICATIONS OR ADDITIONS TO
INFRASTRUCTURE. EXCEPTION ARE
YOU TESTING THESE NEEDS IS
COMPLEX AND BASED ON THE BEST
INFORMATION AVAILABLE AT ANY
GIVEN POINT. MASTER PLAN ANNUAL
REPORT WHICH IS RELEASED EACH
JANUARY FOR THE PRIOR CALENDAR
YEAR INCLUDES MUCH INFORMATION
ABOUT CITIES HERE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. TO PROVIDE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE INFORMATION IN
RESPONSE TO THE LEGISLATURE'S
DESIRE FOR MORE COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT CITY SCARS
WITH SAUDIS AND THEIR NEEDS.
CDCR INTENDS TO PROVIDE IN
FUTURE FASTER PLAN ANNUAL
REPORTS YOUR AVAILABLE
INFORMATION ABOUT FUTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS INCLUDING
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
INCLUDING FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN AND
CRITICAL DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND SPECIAL REPAIR PROJECT.
THAT SAID WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND STAFF TO MODIFY AND REFINE
THE REPORTING LANGUAGE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT THE SCARS DISABILITIES.
THEIR CONDITIONS AND POTENTIAL
FUTURE PRICE. SO THE ANSWER IS.
TO OUR THE REQUESTED THAT WE
HAVE A LONG TERM PRIORITIZATION
ON THESE PROJECTS YOUR ANSWER
IS NO OR YES. AS I SAID THE
PRIORITIES ARE ARE POINT IN
TIME THE NEEDS ARE ARE POINT IN
TIME AND WE DON'T HAVE PERFECT
INFORMATION OVER A TEN YEAR-
TEN YEAR PLANNING HORIZON- SO
WE'RE COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
AVAILABLE INFORMATION THAT WE
HAVE A BETTER FACILITY. WELL I
THINK THAT'S THE SAME THING
THAT ANY DEPARTMENT OR- YOU
KNOW ANY DEPARTMENT GOES
THROUGH IS WE DON'T HAVE
PERFECT WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
NEXT. FEW MONTHS A FEW YEARS
BUT WE HAVE TO DO THE BEST THAT
WE CAN- AND THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS THIS KIND OF INFORMATION.
OF SO AT. MAYBE THE L. A. O.
COULD COMMENT ON WHAT YOU JUST
SAID RIGHT NOW MISS CAITLYN
AMOENUS- O'NEILL- SO TOTALLY-
YOUR POINT CENTER DORADO ABOUT.
HOW JUST BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
PERFECT INFORMATION RIGHT NOW
TO. I MEAN WE CAN'T PLAN FOR
THE FUTURE WE THAT CERTAINLY
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE- IN FACT.
THERE'S UNCERTAINTY AND POINT
IN TIME INFORMATION IS YOURS
ALL THE TIME IN STRATEGIC
PLANNING PROCESSES SO- WE
CERTAINLY DON'T SEE THAT AS A
BARRIER TO. DOINGS TO ENGAGING
IN STRATEGIC PLANNING AROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS- ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S ARGUMENT THAT-
IDENTIFYING PRISONS WAY TO
PRESENT STAFFING CHALLENGES AND
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES WE ALSO
I DON'T SEE THIS AS PROHIBITIVE
TO- PROVIDING THE LEGISLATURE
WITH INFORMATION ABOUT- LONG
TERM PLANS FOR THE FACILITY SO
THAT THEY CAN MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. AND WE THINK THAT IT
COULD IN FACT- I MEAN GIVEN THE
POPULATION DECLINE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT A PRISON IS
SCHEDULED TO BE CLOSED AT LEAST
ONE. STAFF OUT THERE ARE
ALREADY PROBABLY WONDERING IF
IT'S GOING TO BE THERE PRESENT-
WHICH CAN BE CREATING CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF ANXIETY SO TO THE
EXTENT WE COULD THEY COULD IN
FACT BE A BENEFIT TO STAFF THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY- THEIR LIVES.
KNOWING THAT THEY MIGHT BE
MOVING PRESENCE AT SOME POINT
IN THE FUTURE SO THAT'S JUST A
DIFFERENT- PERSPECTIVE. TO TAKE
ON THAT THAT ARGUMENT- I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS-
BUT YOU MENTIONED SOMETHING- OR
MAYBE I JUST THOUGHT YOU SAID-
OF A PRIORITY BY INSTITUTION-
OR OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE LIST
BY IN INSTITUTION OR DID I HEAR
YOU WRONG BUT IF YOU HAVE A
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE LIST BY
INSTITUTION. WHAT IS THAT AND-
YOU KNOW GIVE US MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT. CERTAINLY
THANKS THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- THAT'S SO AS- HAS
BEEN MENTIONING A FEW TIMES WE
DO HAVE THE LIST OF THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS OF- AT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS AND- THAT
THAT LIST IS- YOU KNOW HAS
SPECIFIC- PROJECTS- BY MY
INSTITUTION. AND I BELIEVE- YOU
KNOW- FINANCES PROVIDED THAT'S
L. A. O. AND IF NOT WE CAN
CERTAINLY- HAVE THAT LIST LIST
PROVIDED. OKAY THAT'S A
MAINTENANCE LIST THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE LIST HERNANDEZ YOU
SAID YOU HAVE ONE. YES BIRTH
FOR THE BILLION DOLLARS. ARE
THERE OTHERS YOU SAID FOR THE
BALL DOLLARS AT I'M NOT SURE
YOU'RE REFERRING TO ONE BILLION
DOLLARS I'VE HEARD THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS- DIFFERENT
NUMBERS SO WHAT ARE YOU
REFERRING TO. CORRECT SO THE
BILLION DOLLARS LAST- IS
REPRESENTS A LIST OF. YOU KNOW
PROJECTS OR THAT NEED DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT HAVE A SCOPE
RELATED TO THEM- AT THE
THIRTEEN BILLION BILLION
DOLLARS IS AN ESTIMATE OF WHAT-
POTENTIALLY THE FACILITIES
COULD NEED- BUT THERE AREN'T
SPECIFIC PROJECTS THAT HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED BEHIND THE
THIRTEEN BUT BILLION DOLLAR
LESS. I'LL OPEN IT UP TO MY
COLLEAGUES. SIR NEWMAN FOR
SECRETARY ZINKE. THANK YOU
THINK MANAGER- IS REALLY A
QUESTION I THINK. FOR THE L. A.
O. IT IS PRETTY CLEAR WHEN WE
SAY THAT THERE ARE TWO PRISON
SCHEDULED FOR CLOSURE YOU KNOW
THAT WE HAVE- I THINK IT'S-
JUST BASIC UNREFUTED FACTS ON
THE TABLE THOSE. THOSE ARE
SCHEDULED FOR CLOSURE AND I
THINK IF WE PRESSED WE COULD.
WE GET CLOSER TO UNDERSTANDING-
TIMELINE AND THINGS LIKE THAT
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU USE THE TERM
LIKELY SCHEDULED FOR CLOSURE.
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THE
DEFINITION OF THAT I MEAN WHAT
WHAT IS YOUR WORKING DEFINITION
I DON'T KNOW- I MEAN I KNOW
WHAT IT MEANS IS IN LAYPERSON'S
TERMS THAT FOR SOMEBODY
SOMEWHERE IS MANDATORY NATION
THAT- MORE PRISONS ARE IN THAT
CATEGORY I'M JUST WONDERING.
WHAT'S BEHIND THAT WHAT WHAT
INSPIRES THAT PHRASEOLOGY
LIKELY SCHEDULED FOR CLOSURE.
THIS IS CAN'T FIND ANY ALL. HE
WE DIDN'T WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT
ANY PRISONS BEYOND DUPLICATION
OR INSTITUTION AT THIS POINT
HAVE SPECIFICALLY BEEN
SCHEDULED FOR CLOSURE- WE'RE-
BEGIN TO. AND PRISONS THAT ARE
LIKELY CANDIDATES FORECLOSURE
AND BY THAT WE MEAN- PRISONS
WHERE THE STATE COULD CLOSE
DOWN WITHOUT CREATING MAJOR
OPERATIONAL PROBLEMS THAT WOULD
BE COSTLY OR- VERY DIFFICULT
TO. DEAL WITH IN OTHER WORDS-
FOR EXAMPLE IF THE STATE CLOSE
THE PRISON THAT- RELIED ON A
NEIGHBORING PRESENT IF PROVIDE
KEY SERVICES FOR IT OUR SITE IS
A PRIVILEGE THE STATE CLOSE THE
PRISON THAT WHAT'S PROVIDING
KEY SERVICES TO A NEIGHBORING
PRESIDENT THAT WOULD BE- A
CHALLENGE THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
DEALT WITH IT WOULD HAVE TO
SHIFT. THAT SERVICE TWO OF THE
OTHER PRESENT WHICH ISN'T
NECESSARILY INSURMOUNTABLE BUT
IT'S JUST SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT- OTHER PRISONS HAVE KEY
MEDICAL MISSIONS FOR EXAMPLE SO
THE STATE COULDN'T CLOSE AND
WITHOUT- SHIFTING OUR DATA
MEDICAL CAPACITY SOMEWHERE ELSE
IN THE SYSTEM. ANOTHER CRITERIA
WE. LOOKED AT IS- THERE THERE
BECAUSE- TIONAL. AND IN NEEDS
RELATIVE TO THEIR- INNATE
CAPACITY SO THAT'S SORT OF A-
ROUGH MEASURES YOU CAN THINK OF
IS SORT OF THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OR- OF OFTEN
CONTINUING TO OPERATE THAT
PRISON- AND THEN A THIRD
CRITERIA ONE MIGHT CONSIDER IS
THE LOCATION OF THE PRISONS IN
SOME CASES. IT CAN BE HARD FOR
CDCR TO RECRUIT RECRUIT AND
RETAIN STAFF- PARTICULARLY
MEDICAL STAFF IN SOME CASES
PACKED AT PRISON THAT ARE IN
VERY REMOTE AREAS- THOSE ARE
THREE FACTORS THAT WE
CONSIDERED WHEN WE- IDENTIFIED
OUR PRELIMINARY LIST OF PRISONS
BUT THERE CERTAINLY OTHER
FACTORS. THAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER- WE ALSO NOTE
THAT- IN WE NOTED IN OUR REPORT
ON PRISON INFRASTRUTURE WHICH
WE RELEASED LAST YEAR THAT- THE
ADMINISTRATION PROBABLY IS IN
THE BEST POSITION. TO IDENTIFY
THAT. PRISONS ARE THE STRONG
CAN'T FOR CLOSURE GIVEN THAT
IT'S FAR MORE FAMILIAR WITH THE
DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS AND- IN
UNIQUE CHARACTERISTICS OF EACH
OF THE PRESENCE. YOUR QUESTION.
IT HELPS A LOT AND I APOLOGIZE.
FOR MISS CHARACTERSIN THE
PHRASE WITH LIKELY CANDIDATES
FOR CLOSURE WOULD BE. I THINK
THE WHAT I'M HEARING YOU SAY IS
A RIGHT WAY TO. CHARACTERIZE
AT- IN IN THE LIST THAT YOU
HAVE BASED ON THE CREATURE YOU
JUST LAID OUT IS NEVER REALLY
BEEN- ADOPTED FORMALLY BY THE
LEGISLATURE- OR ANYONE ELSE AT
THIS POINT IS THAT. CORRECT
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY AND
FORMALLY ADOPTED OKAY THANK YOU
THEM JUST CONTRIBUTE CLEAR ON
THE FACTS. S. TO THOSE IN AND
EVEN TO THE TO WHICH OURS ARE
SCHEDULED FOR CLOSURE
IDENTIFIED FOR CLOSURE. I THINK
THE BALANCING ACT I'M TRYING TO
DO HERE YOU KNOW FROM A PUBLIC
POLICY STANDPOINT IS- WAYNE.
YOU KNOW THE RISK OR
CONSEQUENCES FROM A FISCAL
STANDPOINT THAT YOU-
APPROPRIATELY. PUT FORWARD IT
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH MAINTENANCE
YOU WANT TO DO OR START JUST
BEFORE. ONE THESE PRISONS
CLOSES- AND ESPECIALLY THE TWO
THAT ALREADY IDENTIFIED. WITH
THE OTHER PUBLIC POLICY OF
PRIORITY OF MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE SAFE CONDITIONS FROM AND
AN ATA STANDPOINT FROM A
MEDICAL STANDPOINT WE DON'T
HAVE WE HAVE HABITABLE-
CONDITIONS AND WE DON'T. HEAR
THAT TERM THAT OFTEN ASSOCIATE
WITH PRISONS BUT SOLD. OF LEAKY
ROOFS AREN'T. YOU KNOW DRIPPING
ON ON INMATES OR OR- IS A
GARDEN POLICE AND SO FORTH- AND
I AM JUST WONDERING WHAT WE
KNOW IF TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF
ANYONE'S TAKEN A DEEPER DIVE A
REQUESTED- BUT YOU KNOW A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHETHER
OR NOT THOSE CONDITIONS ARE
REALLY REALLY THAT EXIGENT OR
OR WHETHER THESE. MAINTENANCE
CONDITIONS- KENNEDY BE PUT OFF.
YOU KNOW WITHOUT EXACERBATING.
OR PUTTING AT RISK THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR LITIGATION OR
YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT'S ONE
EXTREME OR OR EVEN JUST- UNSAFE
ON HABITABLE INAPPROPRIATE IN
HUMANE. CONDITIONS FOR THE FOR
THE INMATES LIST AGAIN BECAUSE
IF I KNOW THAT WE GO FIX A
MODEL CURRICULUM FOR ONE WEEK
OR ONE MONTH OR TWO YEARS WE
NEED TO CORRECT THOSE KIND OF
CONDITIONS IMMEDIATELY THAT'S
WHERE I'M GOING WITH THAT
THAT'S SURE SURE IN MY OPINION.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
INFORMATION IS OUT THERE OR- IF
THE SYSTEM IS THE CDC OURS
PROVIDING THAT KIND OF DETAIL
INEXORABLY. IN A GO BACK TO
MISTER ALAN ASKING P. AS A KIND
OF DETAIL BUT BUT WHAT WHAT DO
YOU KNOW ABOUT IT. SO THAT IS
EXACTLY THE KIND OF INFORMATION
THE KIND OF ASSESSMENT THAT. WE
THINK THAT THE- DEPARTMENT
NEEDS TO DO AND NEEDS TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE. THE
CONSULTANT THAT DID AN IN DEPTH
STUDY OF THE TWELVE OLDEST
PRISONS DID- PROVIDE A LIST A
SPECIFIC LIST OF RECOMMENDED
PROJECTS. HOWEVER AND ALSO A
PRIORITIZATION ORDER- HOWEVER
IT'S NOT CLEAR NECESSARILY THAT
THE STATE AS YOU POINT OUT.
NEEDS TO PURSUE. ROGER X. FOR
EXAMPLE WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
GIVEN SORT OF THE INDUSTRY
PRACTICES AND STANDARDS THE IF
THERE WAS A FACILITY MADE OF
WOOD OF WHICH THE STATE HAS A
NUMBER OF- INMATE HOUSING UNITS
THAT ARE KIND OF LIKE WOODEN
BARRACKS- THAT THE- CONSULTANT
AUTOMATICALLY RECOMMENDED
REBUILDING THOSE FACILITIES. SO
THAT'S A CASE WHERE IT PERHAPS
THE STATE WOULD COME TO A
DIFFERENT CONCLUSION ABOUT THE
NEED TO REBUILD THAT FACILITY
AND CDC OUR MAINTENANCE STAFF
ARE THE ONES WHO ARE OF COURSE
DEALING ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS
WITH THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO
THEY WOULD. IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR AND DIE
DEPARTMENT ESSENTIALLY IS WHAT
I'M SAYING TO REVIEW THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND TO LOOK AT
THE OTHER PRESENTS. AND SAY
OKAY WHAT IS REALLY IMPACTING-
PEOPLE'S. MY SAFETY AND
OPERATIONS OF THE PRISON AND
WHAT DO WE REALLY NEED TO
ADDRESS- FIRST ETCETERA SO THAT
IS AN EXERCISE THAT WE THINK IS
IMPORTANT TO THIS OVERALL
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENT STRATEGY. IS IT
FAIR TO SAY THAT AT SOME POINT
WERE- EXCEEDING THE SCOPE OF
WHAT THE L. A- WOULD NORMALLY
DO IN IN MAY BE A FAILURE
ANALYSIS- OR AN ENGINEERING
ANALYSIS NEEDS TO BE BROUGHT IN
OUTSIDE OF CDC OR IS UNABLE TO
PROVIDE THE KIND OF DETAIL. IS
THAT THIS UP I'M NOT ASK YOU TO
ADD RECOMMENDATIONS YOU
RECOMMENDATION I'M JUST ASKING
IF THAT'S WITHIN THE REALM OF A
POSSIBILITY A POSSIBILITY THAT.
WE GO DOWN THAT PATH TO GET
THAT KIND OF DETAIL. WE CAN
CERTAINLY- WORK WITH YOUR STAFF
TO DISCUSS HOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO HELP- MOVE THINGS FORWARD-
WE- I THINK IT WENT TO THE TWO
FOOT TO IDENTIFY WHAT PROJECTS
ARE- OUR MOST PRESSING AND ARE
IN NEED FIRST ARE DEFINITELY
NEEDED I DO THINK IT WOULD
INVOLVE QUITE A BIT OF ON THE
GROUND- INVESTIGATION AND
EXPERTISE AND MAINTENANCE AND
FACILITY DESIGN SO THAT WOULD
BE- A CHALLENGE IS IF I'M
UNDERSTANDING YOU CORRECTLY IN
THAT YEAR- I. HOPING WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO HELP- TEN YEAR OLD A%
LIST OF PROJECTS BUT DEFINITELY
HAPPY TO- FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR
STAFF YOU KNOW YOU CAN HELP I
AM JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
YOU KNOW WITHOUT YOU KNOW- I'M
VERY IMPRESSED BY YOUR THE
FESTIVAL IL. BUT I'M ALSO. MY
OWN INITIAL ANALYSIS IS THIS OR
DISCERNMENT IS TELLING ME THAT
AT SOME POINT WE REACH THE
CAPACITY OF L. A- AND WE GET
BEYOND IT WHEN WE START GETTING
INTO STRUCTURAL DETAIL WERE
FAILURE IS LIKELY TO OCCUR NEXT
WERE. THE IMAGINEERING- IS IT
IS AN ISSUE OR STRUCTURAL
PROBLEMS OR AN ISSUE THAT I'M
JUST SICK I WAS JUST SUGGESTING
AND I'M HAPPY TO TALK TO MORE
OFFLINE ABOUT THAT IS TO AT
WHAT POINT- DOES DOES THE
LEGISLATURE JUST. FOR CALL IN.
OR DIRECTOR DEMAND- RESOURCES
IN ON APPROPRIATIONS TO A TO
GET THAT WORK DONE YOU KNOW BY
THE PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS
WOULD SPECIALIZE IN THAT SIDE
OF IT IN AND I THINK YOU JUST
AFFIRMED THAT THERE THERE
CERTAINLY IS A POINT WHERE IT
GETS BEYOND YOUR EXPERTISE- SO
I'M HAPPY TO TALK TO YOU MORE
ABOUT THAT OFFLINE ONE LAST
QUESTION- WANT ONE LAST
QUESTION- WITH. REGARD TO.
THESE LIKELY CANDIDATES AND-
EVEN THE TWO SCHEDULED FOR
CLOSURE ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY-
THE DALLAS IS ON THE JUST
ADAPTIVE RE USE. OF THOSE
BUILDINGS I MEAN IS THAT EVEN A
THING. IN TERMS OF OPTIONS FOR
WHAT TO DO WITH THE FACILITIES
AFTER THEY'RE CLOSED YEAH
CORRECT WONDER PRESENT YES SO
THIS IS SOMETHING WE
RECOMMENDED- THAT DEPART DID
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO IS TO PROVIDE
A LIST OF OPTIONS FOR- THE
FUTURE AT LEAST TWO PRESENTS.
BERMAN HAS COMMITTED TO
CLOSING- FOR IT THERE ARE YOU
KNOW READ REVIEWS COULD- ONE
EXAMPLE THAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW ACTUALLY IS THE DEPARTMENT
PROPOSING TO REUSE AN EXISTING
CLASS CLOSED PRISON AS A
TRAINING FACILITY- I DON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER OPTIONS. OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD AS FAR AS REVIEWS.
BY EIGHT SORRY GO AHEAD. RIGHT
THAT'S WHAT I THAT'S WHAT I
NEED TO KNOW FOR NOW IS TO HOW
FAR WE'VE GOTTEN WITH THAT IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'VE ASKED FOR
THAT ARE SUGGESTED THAT IN-
THERE'S A LIMITED. ANALYSIS SO
FOR FEEDBACK- EVEN FROM CDCR I
ASKED HIM IN PART BECAUSE IF
THERE ARE. IN THE ADAPTIVE
REUSES FOR PRISONS THAT GO
BEYOND. THIS AGENCY BEYOND CDC
ARE- SHOULD WE WANT TO KNOW
THAT THIS WAS IN THE CONTEXT
TRYING TO BRING THIS BACK TO
MAINTENANCE AGAIN IT MAKES A
LOT MORE SENSE TO PUT A ROOF ON
A BUILDING THAT ANOTHER AGENCY
OR DEPARTMENT WITHIN THE STATE
HAS AN INTEREST IN- OR IS BEING
NO SURPLUS TO SOMEBODY WHO
NEEDS A BUILDING WITH A ROOF ON
IT SO THAT THAT'S WHERE I'M
GOING I CAN TALK TO MORE- AS
YOU SUGGESTED. OFFICE TO OFFICE
SO TO WIN THE TIE UP THE WHOLE-
COMMITTEE WITH THIS I DON'T
KNOW IF ANY OF WHAT I JUST
ASKED- I DO WANT TO DENY- THIS
ROMAN IS IT WILL BE OPPORTUNITY
TO. TO HE TO MAKE A BRIEF
RESPONSE TO ANY OF THAT OF
MEDICARE IF THAT'S OKAY WITH
YOU SURE. STONE JUST NAMING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGAIN I
JUST WANTED TO KIND OF
HIGHLIGHT IT IT'S MORE THAN
JUST INFRASTRUCTURE THAT YOU
MINISTRATION THE DEPARTMENT
CONSIDER ONE WE'RE LOOKING AT
REASONS TO CLOSE IT IT'S A BIG
COMPONENT BUT THERE ARE ALSO
OTHER ISSUES- THANK WHEN FOR
EXAMPLE WAS IDENTIFIED BY THE
LA- BUT HAS A VERY SPECIALIZED
POPULATION IN HOUSING GET
THROWING ME IN AND ALSO HAS
EXTREMELY GOOD- PROGRAMMING FOR
INMATES AVAILABLE THERE BECAUSE
OF ITS PROXIMITY IN THE BAY
AREA- HAVE A LOT OF STAFFING
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AGAIN
BECAUSE OF THE SERVICE LOCATION
SO THERE ARE MULTIPLE FACTORS
INVOLVED BEYOND JUST
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS FOR THE
COST TO KEEP. THE FACILITY
OPERATING. AS FAR AS THE SENATE
QUESTION REGARD. EVENTUALLY YOU
FOR EVENTUAL TO. ON THE ADMIN.
IS CONSIDERING OPTIONS WHICH IS
WHY AS PART OF THAT- FUNDING
FOR DUPLICATION INSTITUTE THIS
YEAR WE'RE PROPOSING. TO
MAINTAIN ASPECTS CERTAIN
MINIMUM NUMBER OF THE CITY
STAFF AT THE PLANT OPERATIONS
AT THE FACILITY CAN BE
MAINTAINED IN WORKING ORDER. AS
WE WORK TOWARDS FINAL
DISPOSITION INTENTIONAL SURPLUS
OR OTHER OPTIONS FOR USE. I'M
SO EVEN IF WE TO CLOSE A PRISON
IT IS IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN-
FACILITIES AT THAT INSTITUTION
AND- FACILITY- AND AS SENATOR
PER CASE YOU MENTIONED- ARE.
ENTERTAINING BUT HE SAID HE WAS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND OFTEN
CASES YEAH EMPHASIZE FIRE LIFE
SAFETY ISSUES. THINGS LIKE
COLLAPSING ROOFS OR FIRE
SUPPRESSION SYSTEMS THESE ARE
OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT
REALLY CAN'T BE JUST
MAINTAINED. AS A POTENTIAL
CLOSURE SEVERAL YEARS OFFICE
THAT IS A POSSIBILITY IT'S JUST
TOO PROBLEMATIC FOR LIKE LEON
LITIGATION. FOR OBVIOUSLY THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF STAFF. AND
INMATES AT THOSE INSTITUTIONS.
I WANNA- SAY. HI KAREN I'M SURE
MY COLLEAGUES CARED DEEPLY
ABOUT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THE STAFF IN THESE PRISONS OF
THE OF POPULATION THOSE MEN AND
WOMEN WE CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
THEM. THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE
NINE ARE PUTTING US IN THE
POSITION OF EVALUATING WHETHER
OR NOT WE SHOULD DO THE REPAIRS
OR THE THINGS THAT ARE NEEDED-
OUTLINED THIS IS ABOUT HAVING A
MORE RESPONSIBLE APPROACH TO
THOSE NEEDS FULFILLING THE
NEEDS OF THOSE MEN AND WOMEN
ARE INSIDE THE PRISONS BUT IT'S
ALSO A RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE
HAVE AS A AS A LEGISLATURE. AND
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR ME
THAT WE HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF
THESE LONG TERM INVESTMENTS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
COMMITTED TO A LONG TERM PRISON
CLOSURE PLAN OF THE THAT WE
AVOID SCENARIOS IN WHICH WE ARE
MAKING UNNECESSARY INVESTMENTS
AND WE UNDERSTAND WHY CERTAIN
PROJECTS ARE BEING CHOSEN OVER
OTHERS- SO- WE HAVE GOT TO GET
TO GOT TO MOVE THIS FORWARD AND
EVERYTHING THAT YOU IDENTIFY
MISTER ADLEMAN ABOUT ALL THE
CONSIDERATIONS FINE. LET'S PUT
THOSE CONSIDERATIONS INTO A
PLAN AND MOVE US ALL FORWARD
BUT WE ARE VERY MUCH LACKING IN
THE KIND OF- INFORMATION THAT
WE NEED THE STRATEGY THAT WE
MADE AND THE KIND OF
INFORMATION AND STRATEGY THAT
WE WOULD EXPECT FROM ANY
DEPARTMENT OF SO WITH THAT I
JUST THE- YES I'M SORRY. YES
YES OF COURSE THE CENTER NEWMAN.
AND I APOLOGIZE SO I MY
QUESTION PROBABLY DENTURES FOR
SOME OF THE DIMENSIONS OF
CENTER CRETACEOUS QUESTION-
THERE ARE A COUPLE POSTED
MENTIONED THAT THERE ARE TWO
NUMBERS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THERE'S A BILLION
DOLLAR. SO FRAZIER RIGHT TO
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFY DIFFERENT
MANAGE PROJECTS BUT THERE'S A
MUCH LARGER NUMBER OF THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS SO I I'D BE
CURIOUS AS TO- WHAT'S THE
SPREAD BETWEEN WHAT'S YOUR WHAT
EXPLAINS THAT VARIANCE. AND HOW
OR HAVE TO WE HAVEN'T SEEN OUR
NEW TO THIS OBVIOUSLY AND SO I
DO APPRECIATE THE OFFER OF A
SUMMARY OF THOSE PROJECTS
VERTICALLY AS THEY ARE
ATTRIBUTED TO SPECIFIC PRISONS-
BUT IS IT POSSIBLE AS WELL OR
IS BECAUSE IT EXIST- THAT THAT
REMAINDER OF. TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS THE VARIANCES THAT ALSO
ATTRIBUTED TO SPECIFIC PRESENCE
BECAUSE TO MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS THERE'S CLEARLY A
VERY COMPLICATED ASSESSMENT
MATRIX THAT IS NECESSARY TO
MAKE DECISIONS OVER EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME- AND THIS WOULD
BE PROBABLY WHERE I WOULD START
SO AT THAT THE FAR END OF
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS THOSE
ARE PROBABLY. GOOD TO HAVE
PROJECTS BUT NOT NECESSARY- BUT
THAT ONE BILLION DOLLAR
THRESHOLD SEEMS PRETTY
ARBITRARY SO- AS IT CREEPS INTO
YOU KNOW THAT SECOND HALF OF
THE THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
YOU CAN SEEM AT ANY GIVEN TIME-
THOSE PROJECTS MIGHT BECOME
MORE URGENT WE'D LIKE TO KNOW
THAT I THINK THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. IN MAKING THESE SORTS
OF JUDGMENTS SO IF YOU COULD
SPEAK TO THAT- I GUESS- MISTER
LEAVE FIRST- BE HELPFUL FOR US.
CERTAINLY SO PERHAPS THAT ON-
YEAH I THINK YOU CAN IT BIG
CORRECTLY THAT THE BILLION I
REPRESENTS A PROJECTS AT-
INDIVIDUAL PERSONS FOR WHICH WE
HAVE HAVE A SCOPE FOR THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IS MORE A- A-
OKAY BASED ON DISABILITY
CONDITIONS AND- BUT THERE ARE
NO SPECIFIC PROJECTS- LINES-
THE FACT THAT NUMBER- WE KNOW
WE HAVE A LOT OF. AGING
SYSTEMS- IN IN THE PRISONS AND-
YOU KNOW I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE PROCESS OF HOW
PROJECTS GET INTO GET INTO THE
USE SO THIS REALLY STARTS IN
THE FIELD AT EACH INDIVIDUAL
INSTITUTIONS. AND IS OVERSEEN
BY THE CORRECTIONAL PLANT
MANAGERS- AND THE WARDENS AND
THEIR MAGIC MANAGEMENT TEAMS
HAVE DAY TO DAY RESPONSIBILITY
FOR OVERSEEING SAFE AND
FUNCTIONAL FACILITIES. I EACH-
INSTITUTION HAS A M. I MEAN
IT'S BUDGET- WHICH HAD HAS BEEN
A GRANTED IT- IN RECENT YEARS-
WHICH IT WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT- GOING FORWARD- SO
THAT MORE PROBLEMS CAN BE
ADDRESSED EARLIER IN THEIR
LIFECYCLE TO AVOID- MAJOR.
INFRASTRUCTURE FAILURES- JUMPED
ON THE ROAD. ADAM MY VISION THE
FACILITY ADDING INCOMES
CONSTRUCTION MANAGED DIVISION
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ADVISING
DEPARTMENTAL LEADERSHIP
INFORMING PRIORITIZATION OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEYOND THE
ASK YOU PRISON MAINTENANCE
STAFF. ON AN ANNUAL BASIS-
PROJECTS- WITH- INTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING WRITTEN
OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS AND- OF
COURSE SERVICES AS WELL AS
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
PRIORITIZE THE MOST CRITICAL
REPAIRS- THIS INCLUDES DECIDING
WHICH PROJECTS SHOULD MOVE FROM
INSIDE FULL- OF THIS BILL WHICH
IS THE BILLION DOLLAR LAST
NIGHT INTO A DESIGN EFFORT AND
THEN SUBSEQUENTLY. INTO A
CONSTRUCTION AFTER. IS THAT HOW
DO I KNOW THAT THAT THAT'S WHAT
I MEAN THAT GIVES US SOME
INSIGHTS RIGHT I GUESS NOW I'D
SWITCH TO MISS O'NEILL. IT IT
DOES SEEM AS IF BETWEEN THE
CONTACTS IS CONVERSATION IT
WOULD BE NOT ONLY USEFUL BUT
PROBABLY NECESSARY. TO AS WE
LOOK FORWARDAND CONSIDER
CANDIDATES FOR CLOSURE OR
MERGER WE JUST HOW TO ALLOCATE
RESOURCES. I'D BE VERY GOOD TO
HAVE SHOWN. ATTRIBUTION OR PATH
OF PORTION OF THOSE FUNDS
ACROSS THE SYSTEM. SO WE WHO
ARE MAKING BUDGET DECISIONS
HAVE A GOOD IDEA AS TO WHAT'S
FIRST PRIORITY WHAT SECOND
PARTY BUT- WE CAN MEASURE THAT
AGAINST. THAT SOME YOU KNOW
SOME OTHER OBJECTIVES AND
CONSIDERATIONS VERTICALLY
CLOSURES SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO BRING THAT QUICKLY THEN IT
PROBABLY MOVE ON. WE SHOULD.
THIS IS CAITLIN O'NEILL. I'M
I'M NOT SURE I FULLY UNDERSTAND
YOUR QUESTION IT'S A QUESTION I
GUESS BORN OUT OF IGNORANCE
MAYBE SO THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS HAS A TON OF MONEY- AND
SO IT SEEMS WE'VE BEEN OFFERED
A LIST THAT THAT THAT ACCOUNTS
FOR A BILLION OF THAT THIRTEEN-
BE PROBABLY HELPFUL IN SOME
FASHION TO HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT WHERE THE
NEXT SET OF INVESTMENTS MIGHT
BE NECESSARY PARTICULARS WE
CONSIDER- THE ANNUAL BUDGET THE
DECISION BUT JUST IMPORTANTLY.
LOOKING DOWN THE ROAD TO YOUR
POINT EARLIER LIKELY
CANDIDATES- FOR CONSOLIDATION
RIGHT OKAY I AM I UNDERSTAND
THANK YOU YES- HAVING THAT
PRIORITIZATION WILL BE OF
COURSE VERY IMPORTANT TO BE
ABLE TO STAGE THESE PROJECTS
OVER INTENTIONALLY A DECADE OR
TWO- AS A AS RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THIS WORK- AND SO
NEED. AS A PART OF OUR
RECOMMENDATION AND IS A PART OF
THAT SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE THAT WAS ADOPTED LAST
YEAR WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT- ESSENTIALLY- DOING
IN. OF A ALL WHAT IT KNOWS
CURRENTLY BASED ON THESE
VARIOUS LISTS OF PROJECTS AND
SOURCES OF INFORMATION- KENNY
LOOK AT HOW IT IS REALLY
AFFECTING OPERATIONS IS WHAT IS
THE MOST CRITICAL FIFTY ISSUES
HERE- AND- A SYMBOL OF THOSE
PROJECTS THAT HE SAID TO
IDENTIFY AND- IDENTIFY WHAT'S
THE MOST PRESSING SO WE CAN
START ON THOSE BUT ALSO THIS
IS. AN OPPORTUNITY REALLY TO
THINK ABOUT HOW HOW THE STATE
WANTS ITS PORTFOLIO OF PRISON
FACILITIES TO LOOK IN THE
FUTURE- DEATH SO IT REQUIRES
NOT JUST THINKING ABOUT. WHAT'S
THE MOST PRESSING- SAFETY
CONCERNS WHICH OF COURSE WE
WANTED YOU IMMEDIATELY AND
ADDRESS QUICKLY- BUT ALSO WHAT
WE WANT AND WHAT WHAT WHAT
SHOULD OUR PORTFOLIO OF PRISONS
LOOK LIKE- HOW MANY. HIGH
SECURITY FACILITIES ARE GOING
TO NEED BASED ON PROJECTIONS-
DO WE WANT TO CREATE A GREATER
EMPHASIS ON FOR EXAMPLE
FACILITIES THAT ARE DESIGNED
WITH- MORE REHABILITATIVE
MINDSET IN PLACE COULD WE
ACHIEVE OPERATIONAL SAVINGS BY.
CONSOLIDATING FACILITIES IF
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO REBUILD
THE FACILITY ANYWAY MAYBE WE
WANT TO THINK ABOUT WHERE IT'S
LOCATED AND WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT ARE SO. SO
IT'S KIND OF. BOTH I. FIRST
THOSE KEY PRESSING ISSUES FOR
HEALTH LIFE SAFETY X. SENTARA
AND ALSO THINKING LONG TERM
ABOUT. IN OTHER WORDS SORT OF
TAKING THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
THINK LONG TERM ABOUT- THAT
FUTURE OF SUCH. A PRESENCE.
DOES THAT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
AS WELL THAT VERY WELL SO IF
YOU START I GUESS I I'D LOVE TO
HEAR VERY QUICKLY FOR MISTER
ADELMAN- YOU'VE- HAD. MENTIONED
I'VE GOT A COUPLE OF CASES HERE
THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS VERY
COMPLICATED NOBODY WOULD
DISPUTE THAT- BUT IT DOES SEEM
REASONABLE FOR. WE THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE. SOME
EXPECTATION OF GREATER INSIGHT-
YOU KNOW GREATER CLARITY
GRANULARITY FROM FORD SO- IF
YOU COULD PLEASE SPEAK THAT
THAT PARTICULAR REFERENCE TO MR
O'NEILL'S COMMENTS ARE TO BE
GRATEFUL. I THINK YOU HAVE FOR
THE LONG TERM PLANNING FOR
CAESARS CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
THAT ACTUALLY DEFERRED TO ONE
OF FONG FINANCE CAPITAL EIGHT
ANALYST TO HELP ON THE LONGER
TERM RISING FOR PROJECTS. IN
PLANNING. THERE'S YOUR ANSWER.
LET'S MOVE ON. MADAM CHAIR IF I
pMAY YES GOOD. ALL THIS IS ERIN
EDWARDS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I DID WANT TO JUST TO
CLARIFY- ONE THING ABOUT THE
THIS THIS NOTION OF A LONG TERM
PRISON CLOSURE PLAN WELL THE
FIRST THING I WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR IS THAT. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
ADJUSTING THE PRESENT CAPACITY
AS WE CAN WHICH IS SAVINGS AND
I THINK- THAT IS WHY YOU'RE
SEEING THAT WE HAVE COMMITTED
TO THE CLOSURE OF TWO
PRESIDENTS I AND WE'RE WE'RE
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT AS
TRANSPARENTLY AS WE CAN- I'M
PROVIDING THE NOTIFICATIONS THE
LEGISLATURE AS TIMELY AS
POSSIBLE- WHICH AGAIN IS WHY
WE'VE COMMITTED WITH WITH-
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IN THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR. PROVIDING
NOTIFICATIONS THE LEGISLATURE-
BY JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- ABOUT WHICH WHICH IS THAT
WHICH PRISON WE INTEND TO CLOSE
NEXT- WE WERE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE NOTIFICATION- WHICH
WILL PRESENTLY INTENDS TO CLOSE
FIRST WHICH TURNED OUT TO BE
DVI MY ANUARY OF THIS YEAR WE
DID THAT SEVERAL MONTHS EARLY I
RECOGNIZE THE DESIRE FOR THIS
INFORMATION EVERYONE WANTED TO
BE ABLE TO PLAN. ACCORDINGLY
AND WE HAVE DONE SO- I DO WANT
pNOTION THAT- WE HAVE YOU KNOW
THIS THIS SHORT LIST OR THAT WE
CAN COME UP WITH A SHORT LIST
OF PRISONS THAT ARE LIKELY TO
BE FLOWS IN THE FUTURE- YOU
KNOW OUR PERSPECTIVE IS THAT AT
THIS POINT- WE CAN ONLY COMMIT
TO CLOSING TWO PRESENTS- THE
THERE ARE FAR TOO MANY UNKNOWNS
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO SAY FOR
CERTAIN WILL BE ABLE TO CLOSE
AN ADDITIONAL. THREE PRISONS IS
THAT WE HAVE SUGGESTS OR EVEN
EVEN OFF A THIRD ONE BEYOND THE
SECOND THE TWO THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW IT YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF
UNPRECEDENTED PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS A PANDEMIC WHICH IS
TREMENDOUSLY IMPACT ALL
OPERATIONS WITHIN CDCR- IT'S
INCREASED THE NEED FOR SOCIAL
DISTANCING OUR INSTITUTIONS.
I'M SO I THINK IT'S A LITTLE
BIT- TOO SIMPLISTIC TO SIMPLY
LOOK AT THE POPULATION. TRENDS
AND SAY WELL THE POP IS DOWN
TODAY AND WE EXPECT TO BE DOWN
THE FUTURE WE SHOULD BE. AND
IDENTIFY PRISONS FOR CLOSURE-
WE DON'T KNOW IS WHAT SHE
ACTUALLY HAVE AND I IS BY TO BE.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR PRISONS STATE- AND WE HAVE.
FOR THE JUST WITHIN THOSE
INSTITUTIONS. ARE IN OBVIOUSLY
CALL PRISON MAKES THAT MUCH
MORE. SO THAT IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT'S AT THE TOP OF
OUR- FIVE THINKING IT AS WE
WERE TRYING TO IDENTIFY WHAT
WHAT THE- JUSTIN SHOULD BE TO
PRISON CAPACITY IN THE FUTURE.
THE OTHER THING I DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE IT'S CLEAR IS THAT
THE PRACTICE OF. PROJECTING
WHAT THE- POPULATION BE IN THE
FUTURE- IS A VERY DIFFICULT
ONE- IT APARTMENTS I HAS A VERY
SOPHISTICATED MODEL AND THEY'RE
VERY GOOD AT PREDICTING WHAT
THE POPULATION WILL BE. ONE OR
TWO YEARS IN THE FUTURE. BUT
ONCE YOU GET BEYOND THAT TIME
RISE IN THE START OF MY THREE
FOUR YEARS- FIVE YEARS. IT IS A
VERY DICEY PROPOSITION AND
THAT'S NOT AN INDICTMENT OF THE
DEPARTMENTS IT'S JUST A
REFLECTION IF YOU LOOK BACK YOU
KNOW OVER THE LAST. TEN FIFTEEN
YEARS HAVE BEEN SO MANY POLICY
CHANGES IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
I'VE BEEN IN CHANGES IN THE
CRYPT AND CRIME TRENDS THAT
REALLY IMPACT OF THE PRISON
POPULATION SO. FOR US TO BE
SITTING HERE IN PLANNING TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE A PRISON
THREE YEARS BASED ON A
POPULATION PROJECTION. IS NOT
REALLY SOMETHING WE'RE
COMFORTABLE. DOING AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. TO MANY
UNCERTAINTIES. AND AS WAS NOTED
BY MY COLLEAGUE THERE ARE-
MAJOR RAM OF. PETITIONS
OPPOSING PRESENTS MAJOR IMPACTS
FOR THE STAFF THAT WORK THERE-
FOR THE INMATES THAT ARE IN
THOSE. FACILITIES AND FOR THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES AND WE
DO NOT WANT TO START ON A PATH.
TO DO THAT UNTIL WE'RE 1100%
SURE THAT WE CAN DO THAT SO-
JUST WANTED TO SHOW. RESPECT
ABOUT THE PRISON CLOSURE PLAN
AGAIN WE FULLY UNDERSTAND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTING
GETTING US- IT'S- DEFINITELY
TOP OF OUR MINDS WE'RE
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING US AS WE
CAN- BUT WE DO NEED TO BE
CAUTIOUS ABOUT. MAKING A LOT OF
THOSE LONG TERM DETERMINATIONS.
TO DEFEND WITH. THANK YOU. SIR
I COULD I'D APPRECIATE THAT
FEEDBACK WE RESPECT.
PROSPECTIVE CLOSE. BUT I WANT
MAKE CLEAR THAT THINK I THINK
IT'S BECAUSE- THAT THAT'S NOT
OUR- SO FRAMER. HERE IT ALSO
INCLUDES. HOW DO WE HAVE AN ON
GOING BASIS IRRESPECTIVE OF THE
QUESTION. THANKS MARC DECISIONS
ON PRIORITIZING BUDGET FUNDS
AGAINST THIS VERY LARGE NUMBER-
THAT HAS BEEN ALLUDED TO- IN SO
IT IT IT YOU KNOW IT MAY NOT BE
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS BUT
IT'S ALSO DEFINITELY NOT ONE
BILLION EITHER IT'S PROBABLY
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SO WE NEED
BETTER CONTEXT I THINK- FOR
MAKING MAKES THOSE SORTS OF.
DECISIONS ON IT SO WE CAN MAKE
GOOD ALLOCATIONS- AND GET
MAXIMUM VALUE FOR THOSE
LOCATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I THINK WHAT I'M AT LEAST
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR IS A MUCH
MORE. INTEGRATED BOB PLANNING
AND STRATEGY FOR THE FUTURE. OF
OF- CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND OUR
PRISON SYSTEM. MEAN THE. PRISON
POPULATION IS GOING DOWN. AND
OUR- OF POLICIES AND ACROSS THE
STATE AND I THINK ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO SEE THAT IN SOME
WAY SHAPE OR FORM SO- WHAT I'M
LOOKING FOR IS AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR RESPONSE
IN YOUR COMMENTS BUT I'M
LOOKING FOR IS HOW DOES THIS
ALL FIT IN. AND IT'S GOTTA MAKE
SENSE ALL TOGETHER IN AN
INTEGRATED WAY AND I FEEL LIKE
WE'RE REALLY IN THE DARK HERE
AND WE'RE BEING ASKED TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT OF MAKING THESE
SOME EXPENDITURES- BUT WE'RE
REALLY IN THE DARK ABOUT. THE
UP WITH THE FULL PICTURE FOR US
TO MAKE THE MOST RESPONSIBLE
DECISIONS THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE
WE ARE HERE TO DO. SO- OKAY
SORRY NOT WATCHING HERE- YES
FINANCED PLEASE. FRIEDMAN ROBIN
HARSH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
JUSTIN EDELMAN RECENTLY
REFERRED- DEFERRED TO THE CAP
OUT LAKE COUNTERPARTS AND I
JUST WANTED TO RESPOND SLIGHTLY
TO THAT QUESTION THERE IS AND-
FIVE YEAR PLAN THAT'S RELEASED
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- IF
THE CENTERS ARE NOT AWARE OF
THAT WE COULD POINT IN THAT
DIRECTION BUT IT DOES INCLUDE
ONLY CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTIONS
FOR FIVE YEARS IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY- BUT
IT'S A SORT OF PLANT. AND IT
DOES NOT- INCLUDING THE FIVE
NINE X. SEPARATE IS CAPTURED IN
THE MULTI YEAR. OKAY I HAD TO
HAVE ONE SPECIFIC ONE ON THE
ROOF REPAIRS HERE'S A LIST OF
THE CURRENT ROOF REPAIRS THAT
ARE BEING- ON COULD YOU TELL ME
WHAT THE- AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT'S GOING INTO THE CURRENT.
ROOF REPAIRS IS. YES SIR
CERTAINLY- CHRIS LEAFLET THAT'S
BECAUSE YOU ARE SO THE BUDGET I
DID ACCESS 201-720-1820
NINETEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY
YOU'RE A PROVIDER TO SETTLE-
PROXIMATE LEAD TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
FOR RUTHLESS. THAT'S WHAT YOU
WERE- PROVIDED BUT THE BOARD
SAYS THE CURRENT FUNDED ROOF
REPLACEMENTS THAT CHART. OF IS
THAT WHAT THE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IS
FOR CORRECT YES THAT'S WHAT
THAT AMOUNTS TO OKAY. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH SENATORS ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON THIS NO OKAY I'M
SURE IF I CAN JUST MAKE IT A
COMEDY DOES IF IT DOES NOT
PROMPT ANY FURTHER RESPONSE
BUT- LISTEN CAREFULLY TO OF
SOME SOME OF THE LAST- COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE TO US. THE LAST
SPEAKERS OF AT I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE- HE UPON THIS. PRISON
POP CAN DRIVEN ALLEGE. POLICY
IT ISN'T SO UNPREDICTABLE IF IN
FACT THE LEGISLATURE TAKES UP
THE NOTION. OF THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE POPULATION REDUCTION
TARGETS IN THE PRESENCE AND- I
MEAN THAT'S THAT AND THEN WORK
BACK IN TERMS OF ALL THESE
OTHER ISSUES SO- I JUST WANT TO
POINT THAT OUT AS WE ARE
POWERLESS IN TERMS OF
DETERMINING. WHAT THE
POPULATION IS FIVE YEARS FROM
NOW AS A STATE LEGISLATURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY THAT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD OPEN-
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE-
CDC ARE WHO IS THAT GOING TO
BE. AND THAT IS ACT ME AGAIN
CHRIS LEAVE. YES MR LEAF. HELLO
THIS ISSUE COVERS THAT SIX
CAPITAL OUTLAY REQUESTS FOR CDC
ARE OUT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- SHEPHERDS HOUSES CAL
POLY PROJECTS THAT ADDRESS
CORPORATE MANDATES URGENT
FARLEX SAFETY UPGRADES
REGULATORY. REQUIREMENTS AND
OTHER PROJECTS TO SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT'S MISSION. SO THE
FIRST BOZELL IS FOR A
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATION FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT CORP IS
TO- AT THE REQUEST IS FOR A
FOUR POINT- FOUR POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
AND TOTAL ESTIMATED PROJECT
COST FOR THE PROJECT TURN OUT-
ALMOST TWENTY TWO POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. THIS PROJECT
IS NEEDED TO ADDRESS A HEALTH
CARE FACILITY INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS IDENTIFIED IN THE
RECEIVERS TURNAROUND PLAN OF
ACTION- THIS PHASE TWO INCLUDES
RENOVATIONS AND ADDITIONS TO
THE PRIMARY CARE CLINIC. IN
DISABILITIES A. B. C. AND D. AS
WELL AS A NEW PRIMARY CARE
CLINIC FOR THE ADMINISTRATIVE
SEGREGATION AND- I DURING
CONSTRUCTION SB ZERO DETERMINED
THAT THE EXISTING CONSTRUCTION
FUNDING IS NOT ADEQUATE TO
COMPLETE PROJECTS. INCREASED
COSTS ARE IN TRIBUTE TO A
NUMBER OF FACTORS INCLUDING A
DESIGN ERRORS AND OMISSIONS
RELATED TO THE INTEGRATION OF
OUR ALARM SYSTEM INTO THE SITE
WIDE MONITORING SYSTEM
MODIFICATIONS TO THE
UNDERGROUND FIRE WATER SUPPLY-
RELOCATED AND RELOCATION OF
UTILITY BONDS. ADDITIONAL WORK
IS ALSO REQUIRED RELATED TO
REPAIRS TO THE EXISTING FIRE
RATED QUARTER CONSTRUCTION AS
WELL AS THE HEAD OF PAUL
ASSEMBLY IS WHICH IS A- FIRE-
PROTECTION ON ISSUE. I INCREASE
JOB COST RESULTING FROM THE WAY
IN THIS. RELATED DESIGNER ISN'T
MISSIONS AND COVERED NINETEEN-
RESULTED IN JUST ACROSS FOR
INMATES FORCED LABOR STAFF
FEDERAL LABOR AND FOR THE
EXTENDED. DURATION ON
CONSTRUCTION FOR THIS PROJECT
IS APPROXIMATELY 37% COMPLETE
AND THE PROJECT IS ANTICIPATED
TO BE COMPLETED AND APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE- THIS
PROPOSAL. FOR CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION OF MAN- AIR COOLING
AND FACILITY HEY- CDCR REQUEST
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING FOR THIS
PROJECT OR THIRTEEN MILLION-
EIGHT HUNDRED NINETY SIX
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
PROJECT. FOR THE PROJECT WILL
PROVIDE AIR COOLING SYSTEMS IN
FACILITY A HOUSING UNITS AT THE
I AM MAINTAIN INDOOR AIR
TEMPERATURES AT OR BELOW EIGHTY
NINE DEGREES FAHRENHEIT. UNITS
WERE BUILT IN NINETEEN FIFTY
TWO WHEN AIR COOLING SYSTEM FOR
NOT REQUIRED. SAUDI A HOUSES A
LARGE NUMBER OF INMATE PATIENTS
WERE AGED AND ARE CONSIDERED TO
BE HIGH RISK MEDICAL THAT ARE
MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO HEAT
RELATED HEALTH RISKS. AND THIS
PROJECT IS NEEDED TO MITIGATE
THOSE RISKS INSTRUCTION IS
ANTICIPATED TO BEGIN IN
SEPTEMBER AND COMPLETE AND JULY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. NEXT
PROPOSAL IS FOR THE MEDICATION
PREPARATION ROOM IMMUNITY FIVE
OF CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. SECR REQUEST
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOR WORKING DRAWINGS FOR THIS
PROJECT. THE PROJECT INCLUDES
MEDICAL PREPARATION ROOM AND L.
A. C. AND HOUSING UNIT D. FIVE
WHICH HOUSES ENHANCED
OUTPATIENT PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION UNIT
INMATES RECEIVE THEIR
MEDICATION UP YOURSELF FROM-
THE PREPARATION ROOM WILL
INCREASE STAFF PRODUCTIVITY AND
SAFETY AS WELL AS PROVIDE
TIMELY IN MAY PATIENT ACCESS TO
MEDICATION IN COMPLIANCE WITH
WATER COURT. DIRECTIVES WORKING
DRAWINGS ARE ESTIMATED TO BEGIN
IN JULY AND COMPLETE AND JULY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO CONSTRUCTION
IS ANTICIPATED TO BEGIN IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
BE COMPLETED IN APRIL TWENTY.
FOUR FOR. THE NEXT- SOUL IS FOR
AIR COOLING IN FACILITY F. AND
G. OF THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
REATMENT FACILITY CDCR REQUEST
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR THE
PRELIMINARY PLANS AND WORKING
DRAWINGS PHASES OF THIS PROJECT.
JECT INCLUDES AIR COOLING
SYSTEMS REQUIRED FIRE LIFE
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
REHABILITATIVE TREATMENT
EDUCATION AND OFFICE SPACE
WITHIN FACILITY F. AND G. OUR
HOUSING UNITS AT AT- STAFF TO
PROVIDE INDOOR AIR TEMPERATURES
FOR INMATES TO RECEIVE
TREATMENT AND EDUCATION- OUR
HIGH TEMPERATURES IN THESE
AREAS LEAD TO. NUMBER OF MISS
TREATMENTS AND EDUCATION HOURS
A PRELIMINARY PLANS WILL BEGIN
IN JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ESTIMATED TO BE COMPLETED IN
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO WORKING
DRAWINGS WOULDBEGIN AND MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
ANTICIPATED TO BE LATE IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
INSTRUCTION IS ANTICIPATED TO
BEGIN IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND BE COMPLETELY JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE- PROJECT
COSTS ARE ESTIMATED. TO BE
FOURTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS. NEXT PROPOSAL IT IS
FOR MINOR PROJECTS- AT THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE FACILITY
FACILITY D. DAY ROOM RESTROOMS
IN UNIT THREE OH ONE B. C. D.
E. AND F. EACH OF THE FIVE
PROJECTS ARE ESTIMATED TO COST
THREE HUNDRED AND THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR A TOTAL
OF ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE ONE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND. THE SCOPE OF EACH PROJECT
INCLUDES PROVIDING A TOILET AND
SINK IN EACH DA ROOM TO
PROVIDE RESTROOM ACCESS FOR
PROGRAMMING ENHANCED ISSUE
PROGRAM IN THE NATION'S.
STABILITY REQUIREMENT AND
CHRONIC MEDICAL NEEDS. IT MAY
PATIENTS AND FACILITY ARE OFTEN
MEDICALLY FRAGILE EXPERIENCING
BLADDER AND BOWEL CONTROL
ISSUES AS WELL AS EARLY ONSET
DEMENTIA. IS CONDITIONS OFTEN
REQUIRE READY ACCESS TO TOILETS.
WHICH THE DAY ROOMS CURRENTLY
LACK. OUR NEXT AND LAST IN CAP
OUT LATE AS THE REINCORPORATION
OF A BEHIND THROUGH. THE B.
NINE HUNDRED CHANNEL FIVE.
THERE ARE FIVE HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
PROJECTS. WHOLESOME'S A PRISON
CELL BLOCK FIVE FIRE AND LIFE
SAFETY PROJECTS AND MULTIPLE
MEDICAL DISTRIBUTION
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS THAT ARE
AUTHORIZED FROM THIS FUNDING
SOURCE- CONSTRUCTION OF THESE
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN DELAYED FOR
VARIOUS REASONS. AND THIS
REVERBERATION IS NECESSARY TO
ALLOW THE BALANCE OF FUNDS FOR
MANTA BILLABLE FOR THE PROJECT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. I'M NOT
SURE IF. THE PRINTER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WEEK
CONCUR WITH B. R. WITH CTR.
THANK YOU- AND THE L. A- PLEASE.
THIS ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME.
YES GO AHEAD. WE DO NOT HAVE
BEEN SORT OF THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS HAVE BEEN PUT FORWARD
NOBODY TALKED PERSONS THAT DO
NOT APPEAR TO BE STRONG
CANDIDATES FOR CLOSURE BASED ON
OUR INITIAL ANALYSIS OUR
FIFTIES THE CHAIR WE CAN
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON THE HISTORY AND
BACKGROUND OF THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS.
THAT NOT HAVE BEEN REFERENCED
YOU TALKED ON THIS YEAR IN.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH I HAVE
ONE QUESTION ON THE- CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE FACILITY. THIS IS A
BUILDING I UNDERSTAND WAS
OPENED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN. BUT
IT DOESN'T HAVE SINKS AND
TOILETS I KNOW THIS IS A REALLY
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY
RELATIVELY SPEAKING BUT HOW
COULD THAT BE DOES ANYBODY KNOW.
I CAN TAKE THAT QUESTION MADAM
CHAIR MMHM PLEASE ALLOW ME SO-
THERE ARE NO SPACE STANDARDS
SPECIFYING THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
TOILETS IN A HOUSING UNIT DAY
ROOM- STANDARD PROCEDURE ENDS
AT THE TOP OF EACH OUR- GUARDS
WILL UNLOCK OR LOCK CELLS. AND
THE RECREATION YARD ALLOWING
INMATES TO ENTER OR EXIT THESE
AREAS OF COURSE IN THE CELLS-
THERE THERE ARE A TOTAL OF. ANY
INMATES IN THE DAY ROOM REQUIRE
TO TOILET OUTSIDE OF THIS
UNLOCK IT GUARD WILL PROVIDE
THEM ACCESS TO THEIR CELL.
HOWEVER THEY MUST REMAIN UNTIL
THE NEXT R. LEE- UNLOCK AND
LOCK. IN MOST IRAQI
INSTITUTIONS THIS WORKS FINE
HOWEVER AT THIS PARTICLE HAS
PROVEN NOT TO BE BIBLE DUE TO
THE HIGHER RISK MEDICAL
PATIENTS AND THAT YOU HAVE
BEGINNING. AT THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE FACILITY THAT- HAVE
OFTEN AT THE MEDIA- MEDICAL
ISSUES INCLUDING ALL IN
CONSONANCE WHICH- REQUIRES A
MORE- EASY ACCESS TO WELL IT
LOOKS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF.
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS NO NO
QUESTIONS OKAY WE ARE DONE. YES
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE. PUBLIC
COMMENTS BUT I HAVE TO FIND THE
RIGHT. INSTRUCTIONS HERE. OKAY
OKAY I THINK THIS IS A RIGHT-
INSTRUCTIONS WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
ITEMS RELATED TO PART A. SO
PLEASE ARM FOR ANYONE CALLING
IN PUBLIC COMMENT IT'S ONLY
PART A RIGHT NOW- AS A REMINDER
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M ASKING I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT EACH MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMON
KEEP THEIR REMARKS WITHIN A
MINUTE. LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SAME. NINE- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THE SCENE NONE- AND NOW WE WILL
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
PART A WE WILL BEGIN. IF YOU
LIKE TO PROVIDE A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON PARTAKING IN PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND A
FELLOW PARTICIPANT IN Q. HELLO
K. CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK THE
LINE ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO- LOOK FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. S.
ONE ZERO. HELLO COMMITTEE Q.
OKAY THANK YOU- SEEN NONE THEN
WE WILL MOVE ON- ANYMORE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE FINALLY WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OKAY- CAN
WE HAVE A MOTION ON- THIS YEAR
OUR MOTION IS. ON ISSUE ONE OF
PART A IS TO REJECT WITHOUT
PREJUDICE. SEVEN SMALL BY
SENATOR NEWMAN SECOND BY
SENATOR CORTEZ E- OKAY. SENATOR
OUT WILL WE HAVE A MOTION
THAT'S BEEN SECONDED ON ISSUE
ONE APART AGE THIS IS ON THE V.
S. P. ARSENIC AND MANGANESE OUR
REMOVAL WATER TREATMENT PLANT-
CAN WE PROCEED WITH THE VOTE
PLEASE THE MOTION IS TO REJECT
WITHOUT PREJUDICE SENATOR RAZA
YES SENATOR RAZA YES SENATOR
WILK ALL RIGHT SENATOR WILK HI
SENATOR CORTEZ HE- SENATOR
CORTEZ III CENTER NEWMAN. THERE
NEWMAN HI AND WHAT IS THAT THE
SO WHAT CLOSE THE NFL FOR IS
FOUR ZERO OKAY. THE ITEM IS OUT
AND VOTED ON- WE'RE NOW GOING
TO TAKE A BREAK FOR A THIRTY
MINUTE BREAK. AND BEFORE WE
MOVE ON AFTER THAT WILL COME
BACK AND WE'LL PROCEED WITH
PART B. OKAY. THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
COMMITTEE
FIVE OF PART B. OF THE AGENDA
WHICH WILL COVER TRANSPORTATION
ISSUES INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES CALIFORNIA
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION CALTRANS BOARD OF
PILOT COMMISSIONERS HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY AND THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL-
ISSUES ONE THROUGH SEVEN ARE
VOTE ONLY A WILL BE TAKING THEM
UP AT THE END WHEN WE DO. THE
REST OF OUR VOTING. OF WE'RE
GOING TO START THEN WITH ISSUE
EIGHT- THE DMV OF REAL ID
RESOURCES AND OPERATIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS. COULD WE HAVE-
WHO'S HER FROM DMB IS THAT MR
GARDEN. HERE SENATOR OKAY.
GREAT GOOD TO HAVE YOU MISTER
GORDON GO AHEAD. WE AT LEAST
GOT REPRESENT OUR BUDGETS WILL
BE MAKING THE PRESENTATION THE
OPENING STATEMENT. THEY ARE
BOTH CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. FORTY CONDITIONER
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY ON
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL-
ISSUES ONE THROUGH SEVEN ARE
LEGAL THANK YOU FOR THE LOVE.
AND DELAY. RIGHT THE START THEN
WITH YOU SHE DATE ARE. THE GOP-
RELY. RESOURCES OFF. OUR. THE
CARD. OKAY GREAT HAVING THE
SUPPORT GO AHEAD. IT REGION
ONCE A U. U. P. TO BE BEHIND
THE TO MAY HOW DO WE THIS. ALL
CRISIS. MISTER YES I THINK YOU
ANOTHER ON WHICH IS. NO ONE
TOMORROW I'M SORRY MISTER SCOTT
I'M SORRY. I OKAY CAN YOU WHAT
DID YOU SAY SOMETHING NOW AND
SEE HI CAN YOU HEAR ME JEFF.
FONG BUT WE COULD HEAR ME IN
YOUR BACKGROUND. OKAY ALL.
MAYBE THAT'S THE ECHO I. WE
JUST GOT YOU CAN HEAR ME NOW.
RIGHT THAT'S- I THINK IT'S ON A
LOOP. HONG KONG ALL KONG. WITH
PEOPLE THANK YOU YEAH I THINK
ONE OF DEVICE FONG. YEAH I SOME
PRETTY COOL. HE WE'RE GOING TO
MY VOICE. YOU ALL OKAY SYMBOL
WATCHING YOU ON ANOTHER DAY.
ARE- IS IT BECAUSE FOR YOU TO
WHAT WHAT ELSE WHAT OTHER
SUGGESTING SOMETHING YEAH
SOMEBODY SCREAMING HER. THEY
WERE HEARING BOTH THE ROOM AND
ME TWICE- ROGER THAT'S TIED TO
ME I'M ON MY DEVICE ALL ALONE
HAVE NO OTHER WINDOW OPEN. NOW
WHERE DO YOU WHERE IS THAT
WHERE'S MY VOICE COMING FROM. I
THINK WE'RE ONE CALL. ON APRIL
ON WALLSTREET ON TOWARD ROOM.
ROOM ONE TWELVE. SOMEONE OF HAS
THE ECHO THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
OR ONE TWELVE OF THE ACT. YEAH
I MEAN SOME OF HIS THIS LIVES
THE LIVE STREAM IS THAT MINUTE
DELAY YOUR HEARING THAT ARE
HEARING THE LIVE STREAM COME
BACK. YOUR OFF FOURTEENTH WELL
ONE OF THEM. NOT EVERYBODY. SO
SOMEBODY ELSE. TRY AGAIN HELLO.
I WAS JUST WANTING TO LET'S
HAVE A CONVERSATION HOW WAS
YOUR LUNCH MISTER SCOTT. ARE
YOU OKAY. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES
OKAY OKAY ALL RIGHT I THINK I
THINK WE MIGHT BE MOVING
FORWARD LET'S TRY. OKAY GO
AHEAD MISTER SCOTT. OKAY I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND START WITH
THEN PUT OPENING STATEMENT.
OKAY SO. YES GO AHEAD OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR THANK
EMITTED A BIRTH- MY NAME IS LI
BLOCKS AND HE'S GOT A CHEAP
BUDGET OFFICER OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
WITH ME TODAY AS OUR DIRECTOR
STEVE GORDON. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY BOB HARMON HAS
ONE ISSUE FOR DISCUSSION ON THE
AGENDA AND I LIKE TO PROVIDE A
QUICK OVERVIEW AND IT WILL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE SO FOR THE
FIRST OFFICE ISSUE RATE DMV
RELY THE OPERATIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS THE DFDS
REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN POINT SEVEN PROPOSITIONS.
AT A HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX POINT
THREE MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ZERO
INCLUDING ONE TIME AND ONGOING
FUNDING AS PART OF THE
EXTENSION OF RELATED RESOURCES.
AND OPERATIONAL PREVENTS. ALL
THIS IS A REQUEST FOR REESE THE
CAN THEIR OF THE FEDERAL
MANDATED IDEA WHICH REQUIRES
INDIVIDUALS TO PRESENT A
FEDERALLY COMPLIANT DRIVER'S
LICENSE. FOR ID CARD TO BOARD.
BOB BOB ALL. FOR ONE. ALL OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE SHOULD TO
WANT. TO FOR. LONG POND MISTER
SCOTT IT- COULD YOU. SIGNING
OUT AND SO BACK IN. OKAY LET'S
TRY THAT. ALL BOMB OFF. IN MY
IT. THE LEADERS THE ROOM HE
ADDED THE- I'M SORRY MR GUARD
SAY THAT AGAIN I WAS JUST THAT
HE COULD JUST RIGHT TALK WE CAN
JUST IF WE WAY THIRTY OF LOOP
BACK SO WE CAN TO TRY IF HE IS
THE CULPRIT OR NOT. OF
PARTICULAR. IT WILL YOU AREN'T
THE COLD. AND I NOT THE CULPRIT.
PERFECT THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS.
THIS BERNIE. OKAY HE'S GONNA
TRY TO GET BACK IN AGAIN RIGHT.
YES HE'S COMING NOW RIGHT. OR
NEAR BODIES OF EXCERPTS FROM
HIS COMPUTER THAT HE REALIZED
HE COULD BE RIGHT OUTSIDE THE
STORE BECAUSE OKAY I'M BACK.
OKAY LET'S TRY IT AGAIN MISTER
SCOTT ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA GO
FROM THE TOP OKAY GO AHEAD R.
NOW I NEED TO SEE YOU. AND HERE
IS SINGLE NOW. YES SIR GO AHEAD
ALL RIGHT I THINK WE'RE READY
TO GO. OKAY SO FIRST ISSUED
DANTE REALITY OPERATION
PREVENTS DETAILS REQUESTING TO
R. FIFTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN
PROPOSITIONS AND A HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX POINT. THREE MILLION
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. IT COULD BE ONE
TIME AND ONGOING FUNDING AS
PART OF THE EXTENSION OF
RELATED RESOURCES AN OPERATION
PERMITS B. C. B. THIS IS A
REQUEST FOR RESOURCES TO
CONTINUE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
A FEDERALLY MANDATED REAL ID
ACT. WHICH REQUIRES INDIVIDUALS
TO PRESENT A FEDERALLY
COMPLIANT DRIVER'S LICENSE OR
ID CARD TO BOARD AN AIRPLANE AN
INTERESTING CHARACTER-
FACILITIES BEGINNING OCTOBER
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
CURRENTLY IN ORDER TO OBTAIN A
REAL ID YOU ARE REQUIRED TO
VISIT A FIELD OFFICE. QUESTOR
RESOURCES WILL CONTINUE FINDING
ONE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE EXISTING TEMPORARY
POSITIONS. INCLUDING TEMPORARY
HIRES AND PERMANENT INTERNMENT
EMPLOYEES OVERTIME AND RETIRED
ANNUITANTS. SHOULD DRESS THE
SHORT TERM INCREASE IN WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THE REAL ID-IMPLEMENTATION. THAT WILL
ASSIST IN KEEPING WAIT TIMES AT
ACCEPTABLE LEVELS. IT IS
ANTICIPATED THAT A TOTAL OF
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHICH USED TO
RECEIVE A FEDERALLY COMPLIANT
REAL ID CARD BY THE END OF
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF REAL THE REAL ID ACT IN
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THE
EVERY HAS ISSUED NEARLY NINE
AND A HALF MILLION UNIQUE REAL
ID CARDS. AND WHAT THE EXPECTED
COMPLIANCE DATE OF OCTOBER ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. UBS FOR
PAYING FOR APPROXIMATELY
SIXTEEN MILLION REAL ID CARD
HOLDERS BY THE STATE. AN
ADDITIONAL TEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION REAL ID HOLDERS IS
ANTICIPATED BY THE END OF
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. THIS ESTIMATE ASSOCI
FUNDING. TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
CURRENT CODE RESTRICTIONS
RELATED TO SOCIAL DISTANCING.
POTENTIAL CHANGES IN CUSTOMER
BEHAVIOR IN RESPONSE TO THE
VACCINE ROLLOUTS. ANALYTIC
EVEREST RESTRICTIONS AS THINGS
MOVE BACK TO QUOTE UNQUOTE
NORMAL. AS A RESPONSE THE
PANDEMIC TEAM DMV YEARS FUNDING
AND RESOURCES APPROVED. IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY P. C. P. TO
BEGIN. ALTER SERVICE CHANNELS.
I BECAUSE OTHER OPTIONS TO
COMPLETE GUARDIAN DOES NOT BUT
OUT IN THE COMING OF- PUBLIC
OFFICE. SOME OF THESE OPTIONS
AND XP THE- TRENDS I AVAIL.
VIRTUAL FIELD OFFICE RAN. AND
UTILIZE ROBATA PROCESS ON TO
COME TRASH. WITHOUT ANY PERSON.
THIS INCLUDES REESE THE UNICAMP.
COMMUNICATION CAN AS WELL. TO
ENSURE CUTS ARE OF THE
AVAILABLE SERVICE ALTERNATIVES
A CUSTOMER SERVICE IMPROVEMENTS
SUCH AS A REAL ID AUTOMATED
DOCUMENT VERIFICATION PROJECT
BETTER NOT AS RAPIDLY HERE THE
ANTI. FEATHER RANGE OF ONLINE
CHAT SERVICES TO IMPROVE ACCESS
TO DMB SERVICES OUTSIDE OF THE
FIELD OFFICES. THIS REQUEST
ALSO INCLUDES THE ONGOING NEED
FOR FUNDING FOR OPERATIONAL
PREVENTS THAT WERE MADE IN
RESPONSE TO THE AUDIT CONDUCTED
BY THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
AUDITS AND EVALUATIONS- SIGN.
AND THE COPS RIGHT TEAM IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE YOUR
VIEW PRACTICES THAT ENHANCE THE
FIELD OFFICE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE. FUNDING FOR THIS
WAS ORIGINALLY APPROVED IN
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET ACT. THE
C. P. WAS ONLY APPROVED FOR TWO
YEAR LIMITED TERM WHICH IS WHY
WE ARE HERE TODAY AND THIS UP
THE REQUEST IS TO CONTINUE THE
ONGOING FUNDING TO CONTINUE
THESE INITIATIVES. AND EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO DMV
SERVICES INSIDE AND OUTSIDE THE
FIELD OFFICES. THIS PROPOSAL
WILL CONTINUE BINDING
OPERATIONAL PREVENT SUCH AS
INCREASED MANAGEMENT OVERSIGHT
TRAINING. SELF SERVICE KIOSKS.
AT OFFICE OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS
STOPPING. IT ALSO INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR MUCH NEEDED IT
IMPROVEMENTS SUCH AS
REPLACEMENT OF OUTDATED AND I
RELIABLE TERMINALS. SERVICES
SERGEANTS AND OTHER INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY RESOURCES. NECESSARY
TO SUPPORT NEW ONLINE SERVICES.
WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT THIS
REQUEST RELY THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THE VAST
NUMBER OF PERMITS DEPARTMENT
HAS INITIATED TO IMPROVE THE
SERVICE PROVIDED BY THE DMV.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS LET'S NOT. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- FINANCE.
COMMENTS. YES MA'AM THE
MISSOURI DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO I JUST WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO RESPOND TO- KIND OF
LA- RECOMMENDATIONS- TO ONLY
PROVIDE ONE YEAR OF FUNDING FOR
THE REAL ID. PART OF THE
PROPOSAL- I JUST WANTED TO NOTE
THAT WHILE THERE IS UNCERTAINTY
OVER THE DEMAND DUE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AS
WELL AS A- POSSIBLE PENDING
FEDERAL REGULATIONS WE DO KNOW
THAT THE DEMAND STILL EXISTS-
IN DENYING RELATED RESOURCES
AFTER FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. WILL LIMIT.
VISIBILITY TO CLAM PROCESSING
RELATE THESE IN THOSE OUT
YEARS- I KNOW WITH THAT
TRADITION AFTER ADJUSTMENTS
NEEDED- TO MEET THE DEMANDS- IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE OR
LATER. SIMILAR TO THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THE PROPOSED BUDGET WILL
LIKELY CONTAIN. LANGUAGE THAT
ALLOWS US TO. AUGMENT DMV'S
BUDGET SHOULD WE NEED TO DO
THAT. OKAY CON ELLO ELLO
COMMENTS. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR EUNICE ROW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AT SO WE FIND THAT THAT REQUEST
FOR THE OPERATIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS CUSTOMER SERVICE
IMPROVEMENT IN IT IMPROVEMENTS
IT'S REASONABLE AND CONSISTENT
WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
TO BE SAN VALUATIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT. AND IMPROVEMENTS IN
DEPARTMENT PERFORMANCE SUGGESTS
THAT THE ADDITIONAL RESEARCHERS
HAVE HAD POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S OPERATIONS.
HOWEVER AS FINANCED AS NOTED WE
DO FIND THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATE FOR THAT
TEMPORARY FIELD OFFICE STAFF
REQUIRED AND ACCELERATE COSTS
AT ADDRESSING THE REAL ID
WORKLOAD ARE HIGHLY DEPENDENT
ON SEVERAL FACTORS SOME OF
WHICH ARE FAIRLY UNSER AND
SOUTH. AND THESE FACTORS
INCLUDE POTENTIAL FEDERAL
REGULATE LIKE REGULATORY
CHANGES FOR EXAMPLE IF. THE
REAL ID DEADLINE IS FURTHER
EXTENDED- A TO OTHER FACTORS
SUCH AS CHANGES IN CUSTOMER
BEHAVIOR IN THE PANDEMIC IF.
ASK BOOKS ARE LESS COMFORTABLE
GOING INTO THE FIELD OFFICE OR
FEEL LESS TIME. AT FEEL THAT
GETTING A REAL ID IS LESS
NECESSARY BECAUSE FOLKS ARE
TRAVELING LESS. AND IT KIND OF
JUST LONG TERM CUSTOMER
PREFERENCES AT FOUR- SERVICES
AT THE END B. I'M SO WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE POSITIONS OF
FUNDING FOR THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE OPERATIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS IN NINETEEN
PROCESS- WHICH TOTALED ELEVEN
POINT TWO MILLION AND HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE MILE FIVE
POSITIONS IN. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. I'M BUT WE DO WORK THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED ON THE
BUDGET YOUR POSITIONS AND
FUNDING FOR THE REAL ID
WORKLOADS AND- ADD GIVEN THE
WORKLOAD UNCERTAINTY I WOULD
RECOMMEND APPROVING. THE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE POINT ONE
MILLION AND FOURTEEN NINETY
THREE POSITIONS FOR REAL YOU
WORK WITH FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND IN THIS WAY. AND THE
LEGISLATURE COULD PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENT
WORKLOAD BY REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT COME BACK NEXT YEAR
WITH THE NEW FUNDING POSOF I
WHICH COULD BE INFORMED BY
ANOTHER YEAR OF- DATA ANSWERING
CUSTOMER BEHAVIOR I THOUGHT-
POSSIBLE FEDERAL ACTION. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- MAYBE THIS
IS JUST KIND OF TO WALK ME
THROUGH THIS BUT I KNOW RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC AND
THEN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCES- WE ARE ASKING PEOPLE
TO STAY HOME WE'RE SAYING
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT
NOW TO BE ABLE TO CONTROL THE
THIS THE SPREAD- BUT YET ON THE
OTHER HAND ARE I DON'T KNOW HOW
AGGRESSIVE ARE YOUR EFFORTS ARE
YOU TRYING TO GET THEM TO GO IN
AND GET THEIR REAL ID. BECAUSE
WE HAVE A PENDING OCTOBER
DEADLINE RIGHT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- I KNOW HOW THIS IS
ALL WORKING NOW IT SEEMS LIKE A
REALLY DIFFICULT THING TO DO-
PUSHING PEOPLE PEOPLE TO GO IN
BUT THEN OF KNOWING THAT THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE WANT IN GENERAL
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE NEED- SO
THAT'S JUST ONE IF YOU COULD
COMMENT ON THAT OF THE OTHER
IS- I'M REALLY. CONCERNED-
ABOUT NOT ONLY PAST EXPERIENCES
WITH THE DM B. R. BUT- THE
NUMBER IN THE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE ARE. AND KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT YOU EXPECT WHAT HOW MANY
MILLION PEAK MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
YOU EXPECT TO. OF PROCESS
BETWEEN NOW AND OCTOBER
APPROXIMATELY OCTOBER BUT AS
THE PANDEMIC LOOSENS UP GOD
WILLING. ALL ON THE
RESTRICTIONS MORE PEOPLE WILL
WANT TO TRAVEL BILL REALIZE
THAT THEY NEED A REAL ID. AND
THEN THEY'LL START OF FLOODING
SO I'M I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT. ARE THESE RESOURCES
GOING TO MEET THE DEMAND. OF
THAT WE'RE EXPECTING FOR REAL
ID CUSTOMERS- WE HAVE TO AVOID
YOU KNOW ANY KIND OF A WAIT
LINE- CRISIS. AND DO YOU HAVE
THE TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE.
TO KEEP UP WITH THAT DEMAND.
YES THANK YOU MEDICARE'S A
STEEP GARDEN THAT DIRECTOR AT
DMV- GOOD ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
ABOUT YOU KNOW KIND OF IS IT A
GOOD IDEA TO PULL PEOPLE INTO
THE CURRENT PERIOD WHEN WE'RE
TRYING TO KEEP PEOPLE.
SEPARATED IN HAND HOW SOCIAL
DISTANCING I WOULD CONCUR WITH
YOU THAT IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE AGGRESSIVELY
ATTACKING RIGHT NOW ALTHOUGH
THE DEADLINE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS STILL OCTOBER
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO
THAT IS A HARD STOP AT THIS
MOMENT HOW BAHRAINI CHANGE AND
IN THAT IN THAT GOAL SO AT SOME
POINT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO COME INTO
THE OFFICE WHAT WE'RE DOING
THOUGH TO MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT
OF TIME IT'S BEEN IN THE
OFFICE. YOUR NUMBER OF ACTIVE
HE HEARD THE SO CALLED RAD V.
P. SO WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
PROPERLY BRANDING THAT BUT
REALLY WHAT THAT DOES IS ALLOWS
CUSTOMERS TO DO THEIR
PREPARATION WORK AT HOME ALLOWS
HIM TO UPLOAD THEIR DOCUMENTS
BE PRECHECK SO TO SPEAK TO MAKE
SURE THE DOCUMENTS ARE.
COMPLETE AND VALID FOR- FOR THE
NEEDS THAT WE HAVE SO WHEN THEY
DO COME INTO THE OFFICE YEAH
THEY'RE THEY'RE STOP THEIR
THEIR STAY THERE COULD BE
EXPEDITED SO COULD MINIMIZE THE
AMOUNT OF EXPOSURE THEY WOULD
HAVE. SO WE ARE TAKING BACK FOR
THE TECHNOLOGY QUESTION YOU HE
ENDED WITH WE HAVE TAKEN A
NUMBER OF STEPS OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS TO REALLY FOCUS
ON MINIMIZING THE THAT TOUCHES
WE HAVE IN THE OFFICE TRYING TO
GO TOWARDS A- A NO TOUCH
EXPERIENCE WHICH IS KIND OF THE
NORM TODAY- IN. IN RETAIL I
THINK WE'VE DONE A FAIRLY GOOD
JOB WE HAVE ABOUT A QUARTER OF
OUR TRANSACTION FOR REAL ID
GOING THROUGH THE STOCK IS NO
TOUCH PROCESS TODAY SO THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE THAT TO
YOU KNOW MAYBE 50% MAYBE
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. DEPENDING
ON OUR ABILITY TO REACH THAT
POPULATION WHICH IS PART OF THE
CHALLENGE SO THAT YOUR QUESTION
DO WE THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO
GET OUT PEOPLE CROWDED IN
OFFICE APPS ENTRIES ABSOLUTE
NOT JUST NOT SAFE FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES. IT'S NOT SAFER FOR
THE PUBLIC BUT WE MAY NOT HAVE
A VOTING THAT'S GIVEN THE DHS-
DEADLINE SO WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN PREPARE
FOR THAT EVENTUALITY IF IT'S
GOING TO STILL BE THIS YEAR. TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN DO THAT SAFELY
AND EFFECTIVELY. SO YOU
MENTIONED ABOUTTHE REAL ID
NUMBERS I THINK LEE MENTIONED
THAT. IT'S ABOUT SIXTEEN
MILLION IS THAT WHAT WE SPECTER
HOW BLACK. OF THIS YEAR. NOW BE
ABOUT A SICK MILLION TO. SIXTY
DELTA. WHERE WE ARE NOW AND
WHERE WOULD BE. THAT'S BY THE
END OF SEPT. SO THAT REPRESENTS
A- SIGNIFICANT. IN THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD SEE. ON A
MONTHLY BASIS YOU KNOW SO YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT IN TERMS OF
GET NINE MONTHS LEFT. AT LEAST
SIX OR SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
UP FOLKS WE HAVE TO SEE TO BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THAT NUMBER.
THAT'S ABOUT TO ACCEPT OR SEEN
TODAY SO. THERE IS GOING TO BE
YOU KNOW SOME CROWDING OUR JOB
NOW IS TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE
PREPARED LIKE I SAID WE WANT TO
GET THEM SLOTTED IN SCHEDULED.
AND WE'VE ENHANCED BACK TO THE
TECHNOLOGY POINT. WE'VE
ENHANCED THE ABILITY TO YOU
KNOW SCHEDULE PEOPLE. CANCEL
THE ABILITY TO BE A- REMOTE
CHECK IN TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE
HAVE A SLOT FOR YOU AT A GIVEN
TIME. GOT A LOT OF WORK TO DO
BETWEEN NOW AND THE END AND
SUMMER TO GET THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY AND THE SCHEDULING.
AND THE- CUSTOMERS USING THEIR
SOLUTIONS WHERE WE WANT TO BUT
I THINK WE HAVE THOSE. ELEMENTS
SET UP TODAY. AND OUR JOB NOW
IS TO REALLY. SCALE AND BUILD
ON TOP OF THIS. OKAY SENATORS
ANYMORE. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
GOOD NO. NO OKAY WELL- I AM A I
HAVE TO SAY THAT. I'M A LITTLE
ANXIOUS ABOUT THIS BECAUSE A-
NOR GOVERNMENT IS A YOU KNOW
OUR PUBLIC CALIFORNIANS DEPEND
ON THE SERVICES AND
PARTICULARLY NOW WITH THE WITH
THE DMB- WE SAW SORT OF- IN THE
PAST AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS-
WHAT A FRUSTRATING AND
DISASTROUS EXPERIENCE IT IS FOR
FOLKS WHO I REALLY WANT TO URGE
YOU. WHATEVER YOU NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS WORKS AND THAT
IT WORKS RIGHT- THAT YOU YOU DO
EVERYTHING. THAT YOU POSSIBLY
CAN TO MAKE SURE IT WORKS RIGHT.
THANK YOU MANAGER OKAY GREAT
THIS ITEM IS- BEING HELD OPEN
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NINE. OF THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. OKAY
ISSUE NINE OUR TRANSPORTATION
DEVELOPMENT ACT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
AM CHAD ADDISON CHIEF DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR RAIL AND TRANSIT
IT'S THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
AND I'D LKE TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
SUMMARY OF THE BILL RELATED TO
THE TRANSPORTATION DEVELOPMENT.
I'M THE BILL IS FOCUSED ON A
FEW KEY GOALS FIRST THE BILL
EXTENDS. MANY OF THE CODED
RELATED RELIEF THAT CONTAINED
IN YEAR'S NINE AND IF YOU WANT
SEVEN FOR ONE I JUST FISCALLY.
THIS TIME WAIVES. THAT WERE
CAUSE TRêN AGENCY TO BE OUR
LESS FUNDING FOR TO WHICH SHE-
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
OUR COSTS COMPARED DR COME
RATIO. THANK IN THE BILL
REQUIRES THE TRANSPORTATION TO
PROVIDE REPORT I JUST.
IDENTIFYING UP TO STREAMLINE
THE DATA SUBMISSIONS REQUIRED
TO COMPLY WITH REPORTING AND
PERFORMANCE MANAGEMENT THE
PLANTS. THIRTY THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY SIMPLIFIES.
ELIGIBILITY TESTS RELATED TO
AGENCIES SPENDING STATE FUNDING
OPERATIONS THOSE AGENCIES THAT
PROVIDE LOCAL FUNDING LEVELS AT
OR ABOVE. THOSE PROVIDED IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
NINETEEN. EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THIS IS FOR A FIVE YEAR PERIOD
AND IT OPENS THE DOOR. TO MORE
FUNDING CERTAINTY AND
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW TO PROVIDE
SERVICE TO ALL PARTS OF THE
COMMUNITIES SERVED BY THE
TRANSIT OPERATORS. THE
INNOVATION ENCOURAGED BY THIS
PROVISION MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE UNDER CURRENT PARADOX
RECOVERY. REQUIREMENTS AND THE
OUTCOMES OF THESE PROVISIONS
WILL BE EVALUATED FOR
EFFECTIVENESS AFTER FIVE YEARS.
FINALLY THE BILL EXCLUDES FOR
THE CALCULATION OF FAREBOX
RECOVERY IN OPERATING COSTS PER
HOUR THE COST OF RISK REQUIRING
MANDATED AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITY ACT SERVICE TO THE
PROVISION OF THE SERVICES DOES
NOT NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE FIXED ROUTE.
SERVICES FANSERVICE IT ALSO
EXCLUDES MISCALCULATIONS THE
COST OF FLEXIBLE ROUTE SERVICE-
THAT SO THAT SO THAT THERE IS
MORE ABILITY TO INNOVATE AND
EXPANSION OF SERVICE INTO NEW
AREAS OF THE COMMUNITY THAT
CANNOT SUPPORT A FULL FIXED
ROUTE. BUS SERVICE. IN SUMMARY
THIS BILL REDUCES REQUIREMENTS
THAT NEED TO BE MAPPED FOR
LOCAL TRANSIT AGENCIES TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS ALL OF THEIR
FORMULA BASED FUNDING. AND BY
HAVING MORE CERTAINTY THAT
FUNDS COULD BE SPENT ON
OPERATIONS IN THE COMING YEARS.
AGENCIES WILL BE ABLE TO
CONNECT TO FUNDING CHOICES THAT
WOULD REDUCE THE PRESSURE TO
FOR LOW WORKERS REDUCE
SERVICES. AND ALSO PURSUE
INNOVATIVE WAYS OF SERVING
THEIR ENTIRE COMMUNITY WITH
FLEXIBLE SERVICE TYPES WERE
FIXED ROUTE BUS SERVICE IS NOT
EFFECTIVE OR EFFICIENT. LAST
SUMMER A GLAD TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS WITH SOMETHING. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FINANCE
LEASE. HELLO THIS. THINKING I'M
SURE SIOUX FALLS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I ALWAYS WANT TO CURRY
WE BELIEVE THIS PROPOSAL IS
PRUDENT AND NECESSARY AT THIS
TIME WE BELIEVE THE LANGUAGE
DOES ALLOW FOR LOCALS TO HAVE
MORE INNOVATION AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- LOOK AT
DIFFERENT WAYS THEY CAN EXPAND
THEIR SERVICE AND THAT ALSO
ALLOWS THEM TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
THE SERVICE DELIVERY THAT- WILL
LIKELY BE NECESSARY IN THE
POST. ENDEMIC ENVIRONMENT. AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
WELLS I L. A- PLEASE. I'M NOT
I'M HERE AND YOU MISTER WITH
THE L. A. ASKED SO. I GENERALLY
WE AGREED THAT THE LANGUAGE
SEEMS REASONABLE AND CONSISTENT
WITH THAT- LEGISLATIVE ACTION
TAKEN LAST YEAR FOR. REGULATORY
RELIEF WITH TRANSIT AGENCIES
AND AS THE COMMITTEE STAFF HAS
NOTICED SOME OF THE REGULATORY
RELIEF THAT EXTENDS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS SO THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
CONSIDER WHETHER THEY'RE ON THE
GENERATION OF REGULATORY RELIEF
ALIGNS WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. THANK YOU I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- ON. THE
SAFEWAY FROM- DALY OWES-
COMMENT HOW LONG DO YOU EXPECT
OF THE TRANSIT AGENCIES TO NEED
THIS KIND OF STATUTORY. RELIEF
AND- ARE THERE OTHER CHANGES
THAT WE COULD LOOK AT SO THAT
YOU COULD GET THE RELIEF FOR
FLEXIBILITY THAT YOU NEED
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO. DO ALL WE
CAN TO BE HELPFUL TO THE-
TRANSIT AGENCIES. YES ON THE
GENERATION OF THE RELIEF WE-
KNOW THAT AT LEAST ONE MORE
YEAR OF HEALTH WOULD BE. ADDED
IN REGARDS TO HOW TO CALCULATE
THE FUNDING RECEIVED BY
AGENCIES IN THE PERFORMANCE
REQUIREMENTS- WE WOULD BE GLAD
TO- WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
ACT TO IDENTIFY WHETHER
ADDITIONAL RELIEF MIGHT BE
MIGHT BE ALSO WARRANTED AT THIS
TIME- SO I'VE RIGHT NOW WE ARE
WE THINK THAT ON AT LEAST ONE
MORE YEAR IS WARRANTED FIRST
GETS YOU THROUGH A FULL ARE AT
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE IN
TERMS OF FUNDING ALLOCATION.
AND I THINK THE COMING MONTHS
WILL INFORM US MORE IS TO IS TO
HOW MUCH LONGER THAT RELIEF
MIGHT BE NECESSARY ONCE WE SEE
THE PERFORMANCE OF TRANSIT IN
THE COMING MONTHS OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
CENTERS. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NO IF OKAY SENDGRID
HAS I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A
SHORT ANSWER IF THERE'S NOT-
IT'S JUST SOMETHING. OR MAYBE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT THAT WOULD
BE- OVERALL THOUGH BE WORTH
WORTH GETTING OFFLINE OR BY BY.
ESSENTIALLY AN OPPORTUNITY
REPORT TO US AND THAT IS- AND-
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE HAD SOME
PER DISCUSSIONS INFORMALLY
ABOUT- OUR STUDY COMMITTEE
WHICH IS. THE PROSPECTIVE
ALIGNMENT OF. THESE
APPROPRIATIONS AND EXPENDITURES
WITH- ANY ANTICIPATED RE
AUTHORIZATION OF- OF FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION- ACT IN THE END
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WORK IS.
ONGOING OR STARTED OR
ANTICIPATED WITH THE CHANGE IN
ADMINISTRATION AND- IN THE
CHANGE IN THE CONGRESS. A THAT
WE WITH WE'VE ALL EXPERIENCED
HERE- A STARTING LAST MONTH
BUT- I CAN JUST SEND TO
SUBPOENA. AS AS ONE SENATOR-
YOU KNOW BASED ON MY REGIONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH. OF THESE KINDS
OF ISSUES THAT THERE MAY BE A
NEED FOR US TO. PROACTIVELY ARE
FORMALLY TRAVEL ON UP WITH.
WHAT WE ANTICIPATED FEDERAL
FUNDING HAD TO BE IN A CHANGED
ENVIRONMENT. AND AGAIN I
UNDERSTAND THAT COULD INVOLVE A
TO OUR PRESENTATION SO I'M NOT
ASKING FOR THAT I'M JUST ASKING
FOR. HAS ANY OF THAT WORK
STARTED YET. IN WHETHER HAS ARE
NOT CAN WE GET A- CAN WE GET
THE- NOVECENTO REPORT. OR
FORWARD REPORTED THE NEXT
COMMITTEE OKAY. YES IN CENTER
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT ON THE
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES INVOLVED IN IN
PURSUING SOME OF THAT FEDERAL
FUNDING HAVE ALREADY STARTED
WORK ON HOW TO MAKE SURE THEY
ARE ALIGNING THEIR PROGRAMS
WITH THOSE OPPORTUNITIES- AND
WE'VE ALREADY HAD GOOD
COMMUNICATION WITH THE IN. THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION IN
WASHINGTON. I'M SO WE BE GLAD
REPORT ON THIS MORE AND- YOU
ANY FURTHER INFORMATION THAT
THANK WITH WHAT DOES APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND ALL THE
TO THE- PER TO BE- CAN MEETINGS
TO PICK OUT WHAT THE WAY TO DO
THAT IS YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY. OF NO MORE. OR QUESTIONS
IS A ITEM WERE HOLDING. AND
WOMEN NOW TO- I. TEN IS TENTH.
LOCAL AND- TRAILER BILL. GOOD
MORNING SURE OSMAN'S. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY I MET
TWICE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. FOR THOSE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH US THE COMMISSION
IS THE INDEPENDENT STATE
AGENCIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALLOCATING ABOUT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. TO
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE ELEVEN
APPOINTED VOTING COMMISSIONERS
TO NON VOTING LEGISLATIVE EX
OFFICIO COMMISSIONERS AND A
SMALL STAFF OF ABOUT THREE
DOZEN. BEFORE I PRESENT A
PROPOSAL I WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO CONGRATULATE SENATOR
NEWMAN ON THIS APPOINTMENT LAST
WEEK AS AN EX OFFICIO MEMBER OF
THE COMMISSION. WE APPRECIATED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WELCOME YOU
ONE THAT THE OTHER DAY AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
COOPERATION. WITH THAT THE PARK
TO PROBE THE PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU IS THIS TRAILER BILL. TO
ADJUST THE MAINTENANCE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE LOCAL
STREETS AND ROADS PROGRAM. TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPACTS THAT THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
HAPPENED CITY EIGHT COUNTY
GENERAL FUND. AS BACKGROUND THE
LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS PROGRAM
WAS ESTABLISHED BY THE ROAD
REPAIR AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN. VICE ABOUT
ONE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
FOR BASIC ROAD MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR THROUGH A STATUTORY FORM.
WHAT ARE THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO RECEIVE
FUNDING TO MAINTAIN THEIR
GENERAL FUND SPENDING ON LOCAL
STREETS AND ROADS. TO AT LEAST
THE AVERAGE THEY SPENT DURING
THE TWO THOUSAND NINE TEN
THROUGH 200-011-1250 YEARS.
AFTER THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC. THE COMMISSION BEGAN
RECEIVING FEEDBACK FOR CITIES
AND COUNTIES. REGARDING THEIR
POTENTIAL INABILITY TO MEET THE
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT
REQUIREMENT. THE GENERAL FUND
REVENUES WERE DECLINING AND
THEY NEEDED TO DEDICATE THOSE
RESOURCES TOWARDS ADDRESSING
HOPE IN NINETEEN. IN THE MONTHS
AFTERWARDS TO COMMISSION STAFF
FACILITATED NUMEROUS MEETINGS
WITH THE WORKGROUP. CONSISTING
OF STAKEHOLDERS AND INDUSTRY
GROUPS TO DISCUSS THIS ISSUE-
CONCLUDED THAT SUSPENDING THE
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT
REQUIREMENT FOR THAT NINETEEN
TWENTY FISCAL YEAR WAS
APPROPRIATE SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN SUDDENLY IN THE FISCAL
YEAR WAS ALREADY OVER. THE
GROUP FURTHER RECOMMENDED THAT
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL
YEARS THE MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT
REQUIREMENT SHOULD BE ADJUSTED
FOR EACH CITY AND COUNTY.
PROPORTIONATE TO THE LOSS OF
GENERAL FUND REVENUES
EXPERIENCED. THIS TARGETED
APPROACH INTERESTED CITIES AND
COUNTIES DO NOT LOSE CRITICAL
STATE FUNDS FOR THEIR ROADS
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU
APPROVE THIS PROPOSAL TO HELP
OUR STRUGGLING CITIES AND
COUNTIES I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR WEISS- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YOUR- SENATORS MEMORY
BUT NOT FOR YOU THEN PLEASE
OKAY WELL WE APPRECIATE YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR MAKING
THE PRESENTATION THIS IS AN
ITEM MORE HOLDING OPEN ALL I'M
SORRY. FINANCING AND THE
LAYOFFS ARE JUMPING THE GUN
HERE OF FINANCE PLEASE. HELLO
AGAIN I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
WE AGREEWITH THIS LANGUAGE AND
WE AGREE THAT IT'S NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE THE TEMPORARY RELIEF TO
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING A
DISPROPORTIONATE- FISCAL ISSUES
DURING THE PANDEMIC. WE ALSO
WITH THIS LANGUAGE IS NECESSARY
FOR THEM TO CONTINUE DELIVER SB
ONE PROJECTS AND MAINTENANCE
WITHOUT INTERRUPTION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU L. A- PLEASE. AT
CURRENT. YOU KNOW THROW IT OUT-
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL AT GIVEN
DATE THAT IMPACTED THE PAN AM
MAKE TO LOCAL RESILIENCE WE
FIND THAT HAVE. THE BILL
LANGUAGE TO BE REASONABLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NO
QUESTIONS ARE. OKAY WE
APPRECIATE YOU- IT'S IS A
HOLDING THIS OPEN- AND WE MOVE
ON TO. AT C. ISSUE ELEVEN. THE
HAZARDOUS MATERIAL REMOVAL AT
ENCAMPMENTS. THAT THIS IS
CALTRANS. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR- MY NAME IS STEVEN
CHECK I'M THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER FOR CALTRANS AND I'LL
GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THIS
ITEM- IN THIS ITEM THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING AND
HAVE AN INCREASE OF TWENTY
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR
DEDICATED FUNDING FOR
HAZARDOUS. HAZARDOUS WASTE
REMOVAL CONTRACT RESOURCES-
WITH THESE CONTRACT RESOURCES
WE WILL- BE ABLE TO AID IN THE
SAFE REMOVAL OF HAZARDOUS
MATERIAL. WITHIN THE STATE
RIGHT AWAY PARTICULARLY IN
DENSELY POPULATED AREAS- THIS
IS IN REGARDS TO WIN WE NEED TO
ADDRESS- ENCAMPMENTS WITHIN OUR
RIGHT AWAY. AND SOME OF THE
ITEMS THAT WE FIND IN THESE
ENCAMPMENTS POSE SIGNIFICANT
SAFETY RESCUE CALTRANS
EMPLOYEES. SO THESE RESOURCES
WOULD BE USED FOR CERTIFIED AND
QUALIFIED CONTRACTORS TO COME
IN TO CLEAN SELECT REMOVE
TRANSPORT AND LEGALLY DISPOSE
OF- ENVIRONMENTALLY REGULATED.
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS. WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED A VERY SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE NEED FOR THESE
RESOURCES- AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA- THAT YOU'RE JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO WE'VE HAD MORE THAN A
ONE HUNDRED AND 50% INCREASE IN
REQUESTS FOR SERVICE CONCERNING
ENCAMPMENTS- I RECOGNIZE THAT
BOTH THE STAFF AND ELLIE-
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS ITEM
CONCLUDE THAT THE REQUEST IS
WARRANTED. BUT IT MAY BE
TEMPORARY OR THE NEED MAY BE
TEMPORARY BASED ON THE CURRENT
SURGE AND THE FACT THAT THE
STATE IS DOING ITS- BEST
EFFORTS TO REDUCE INSTANCES OF
HOMELESSNESS- I THINK- THAT
RECOMMENDATION IS- FOR TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM OF- APPROPRIATIONS
PROBABLY PRUDENT. I'M FROM OUR
STANDPOINT IT WOULD BE REALLY
THE BEST POSSIBLE OUTCOME IF WE
DIDN'T NEED THESE RESOURCES IN
TWO YEARS AND- INSTANCES OF
HOMELESSNESS ON THREE RIGHT
AWAY WERE REDUCED IT WOULD BE
JUST THE BEST REVERIE BODY. SO
WE DON'T NECESSARILY DISAGREE
ALL WITH YOUR STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER TECH-
FINANCE. BENJAMIN CALLING
PERMANENT FINANCE. WE WOULD
AGREE WITH THE POINTS MADE BY
STEPHEN CAC IN TERMS OF- THE TO
YOUR RECOMMENDATION WE BELIEVE
THESE RESOURCES WOULD BE NEEDED
ON GOING- BUT- TO REEVALUATE IN
TWO YEARS WE CAN WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO MONITOR
EXPENDITURE LEVELS AND- COME
BACK TO DISCUSS FURTHER. THANK
YOU OF AND THE ALEJO. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND SO YES THAT AS THE
DEPARTMENT- HAS NOTED THAT. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE REQUEST AND
THE PROPOSAL ITSELF IS THAT THE
WORK WITH THIS WARRANT TEN
HOWEVER AND WE JUST HAVE A
SMALL TECHNICAL ISSUE WITH THAT
PROPOSAL THE ESTIMATES OF THE
ANNUAL COST OF HUNDRED AND THIS
YEAR- IF YOU'RE OVER BILL WILL
IS BASED ON THAT LIMITED TO
TWENTY WEEKS OF CONTRACT
SERVICES- AND- THE EXPENDITURE
RATE- FROM SUCH A LIMITED
PERIOD OF TIME WAS EXPANDED TO.
AN ANNUAL RATE AND THAT'S
MAINLY BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
HAS LIMITED CLEAN IT CAN'T
CLEAN UP ACTIVITY IN MORE
RECENT MONTHS. ARE AND WHILE
THAT THAT MAKES SENSE
INCOMPLETE AND ANNUAL
EXPENDITURE DATA MY IN
ACCURATELY CAPTURE THE COSTS OF
THE FULL SERVICE SAYS FOR
EXAMPLE IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THE LAST YEAR FOR WHICH WE HAVE
COMPLETE ANNUAL DATA CALTRANS
SPENT ABOUT FOURTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION FRANKAMP THERE REMOVAL
WHICH IS STILL LESS THAN THE
AMOUNT THAT YOU'RE REQUESTING
THIS PROPOSAL. SO GIVEN THIS
KIND OF UNCERTAINTY AROUND
ONGOING COST WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM FUNDING. OKAY I
JUST- ONE IS A COMMENT THAT-
THE MR CARE ACT THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I KNOW THAT- IN MY
DISTRICT- FORTUNATE
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE MANY MANY
OF FREEWAYS- AND OUT WE ARE
ALWAYS CALLING ON A TO GET- TO
GET YOUR SYSTEMS AND IN THE
CLEAN UP SO IT'S A REALLY. BIG
ISSUE. R. FOR THAT REASON AND
IN MY DISTRICT- BUT I JUST WANT
TO ASK AND- ARE YOU KNOW HOW
CONFIDENT ARE YOU I'M SURE YOU
ARE BUT- YOUR WORKLOAD
ESTIMATES- HOW CONFIDENT ARE
YOU ABOUT THOSE AND- YOU REALLY
THIS ISN'T THE RIGHT LEVEL OF
RESOURCES THAT- THAT YOU NEED.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION- WE'RE AS CONFIDENT AS
WE CAN BE IN THE IN THIS
REQUEST- AS WAS NOTED BY THE L.
A. WE'RE WE'RE WORKING ON
LIMITED DATA THAT HAS BEEN
SOMEWHAT CONFUSED BY THE
CURRENT KOBE CRISIS- CERTAINLY
I THINK ADAM. THE PROPOSAL TO
DO THIS FOR JUST TWO YEARS
WOULD HELP. ALLEVIATE ANY-
ISSUES WERE MIGHT HAVE WITH
UNCERTAINTY WITH REGARD TO
THEIR QUEST BUT- WE'RE FAIRLY
CONFIDENT THAT THIS IS THE
LEVEL THAT WE NEED. OKAY ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS YES FEMIGRA
DOESN'T IS IMAGES SAYS
PROCEDURE IS THIS ITEM THE- TO
BE HELD OPEN TODAY YES OKAY
GREAT THEN I CAN FIGURE JUST AS
FOR INFORMATION BE BROUGHT
BACK- IN. WHAT WOULD REALLY
HELP ME A LOT AS UNDER
UNDERSTANDING- OF CONTEXT A
LITTLE BIT MORE I'VE I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND HAS MY
ROOF REMOVAL. AND I'M SATISFIED
HEARING THE- YOU KNOW THE
TESTIMONY TODAY THE ANALYSIS I
SHOULD SAY THAT. THE NUMBERS
ARE- THEN THE NUMBERS HAVE BEEN
WELL THOUGHT OUT WHAT IT WHA I
DON'T UNDERSTAND ENTIRELY IS-
IS. BECAUSE THE SEQUENCE AND IN
TRIGGERING OF THESE ACTIVITIES
IN OTHER WORDS IS ARE WE ONLY
GOING INTO REMOVE HAZMAT AFTER-
THERE'S BEEN A SWEEP OR AN
ABANDONMENT OF ENCAMPMENT- AND
THEN ONLY AFTER CALTRANS
MAINTENANCE STAFF IS GONE IN
AND REMOVED OTHER DEBRIS
LEAVING ONLY THE HAZMAT. SO
JUST GIVING EXAMPLES OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE WHEN I
SEE CONTACTS SEQUENCES SORT OF.
REGIS ISOLATING THIS ONE ISSUE
OF HAZMAT WHERE I DON'T I DON'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND- NOT SO MUCH
THE METRICS. BUT- YOU KNOW
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF DEALING
WITH YOU CAN'T MISS THIS PIECES
IS COMING IN IT SO WE COULD GET-
YOU KNOW THAT INFORMATION BACK
A WIN THE ITEM COMES BACK THAT
WOULD BE. THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WHO WILL WORK ON
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- I
JUST WANT TO INVITE- THANKING
YOU VERY MUCH FOR- YOUR
RESPONSIVENESS AND IN OUR
DISTRICT AND- I KNOW IT'S
BECOME INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT.
TO GET- YOU KNOW TO GET IT DONE
AS QUICKLY AS WE HAVE BEEN USED
TO IN THE PAST BUT HOPEFULLY
WITH THESE RESOURCES- YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO- RESPOND TO THE
INCREASE IN IN REQUEST SO-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL
THAT YOU DO. THANK YOU. OKAY
THIS IS A TO BE HELD OPEN.
REMOVE ON TO ITEM. OR IS IT.
TOO YES HERE WE GO- ITEM TWELVE
OFFICE SPACE RELATED COSTS.
THANK YOU SENATOR STEVEN
CHECKED AGAIN WITH CALTRANS- SO
WITH THIS REQUESTED WE ARE.
ASKING FOR A ONE TIME NCREASES
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING RESOURCES OF
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY- FOR
OFFICE SPACE MODIFICATIONS AND
MOBILE WORKFORCE TECHNOLOGY TO
ENHANCE OUR ABILITY TO TELEWORK
AND TO FURTHER EXPLORE
INNOVATIONS RELATED TO HOUSING
OUR EMPLOYEES. THIS REQUEST IS
THE SECOND AND FINAL REQUEST
RELATED TO HOUSING ADDITIONAL
EMPLOYEES THAT WERE HIRED ON AS
WE CONTINUE TO HIRE ON. A TO
PERFORM- A GREAT DEAL OF
ADDITIONAL WORK- FUNDED THROUGH
SENATE BILL ONE THE ROAD REPAIR
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACT- THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING ALL THOSE TOGETHER
HAS PREVENTED- PRESENTED A
NUMBER OF CHALLENGES- BUT IT'S
ALSO A WHILE CALTRANS TO
EXPERIMENT AND PROVES THAT. WE
CAN'T REALLY HANDLE- HELLO WORK
ON A SCALE THAT WE NEVER REALLY
THOUGHT WAS POSSIBLE BEFORE.
AND WHAT THIS I ALLOWED US TO
DO AND HOPEFULLY WILL ALLOW US
TO CONTINUE TO DO. IS TO.
BARCLAYS DURING THE PANDEMIC
BUT ALSO ALLOWS FOR US TO- MORE
CREATIVELY USE OUR EXISTING
OFFICE SPACE TO OBVIATE THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL EXPENSIVE
OFFICE SPACE. BY UTILIZING-
TELEWORK. PRACTICES SO BY DOING
THIS ALTERNATELY WE HOPE TO
REDUCE IN THE FUTURE NEED FOR
INCREASED OFFICE SPACE WHICH
MAKES THIS RELATIVELY SMALL
INVESTMENT- ARE MUCH CHEAPER IN
THE LONG RUN. THANK YOU-
BINANCE. HI JAMES OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT WE CAN COVER OF
CALTRANS I THINK IT'S A PRUDENT
STEP IN EXPANDING AND
ENHANCING- CALTRANS ABILITY TO
TELEWORK AND- FURTHER INNOVATE
AS- THE DEPARTMENT SAID. THANK
YOU AND L. A- PLEASE. AT YES WE
DO NOT HAVE CONCERNED WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL THE REQUEST
SEEMS REASONABLE AND PREDATES
DEPEND THAT MAKE AND HOW
TRANSFERRED TO ACCOMMODATE THE
ADDITIONAL I'M STAFF ASSOCIATED
WITH SB ONE IN THE EXISTING-
OFFICE SPACE GIVEN CALTRANS- IS
THAT LARGE STATE DEPARTMENT AND
IN MAY OF BE ASKED LEGISLATIVE
ENTRANCE TO. KEEP AN ON GOING
AT OVERSIGHT OF CALTRANS
DECISIONS INTO AND- ADD
TELEWORK OR AND THEIR
INNOVATIVE WORK STRATEGIES CAN
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU I
JUST HAVE ONE OTHER QUESTION I
ASSUME- MISTER CAKE THAT THIS
EXPERIENCE OF- HOPEFULLY LEADS
YOU TO MORE LONG TERM PLAN. FOR
VIRTUAL OR OR TELEWORK IS
HOPEFULLY IT'S MERGING INTO
SOMETHING THAT'S BEYOND THE
EVEN THE LENGTH OF THE PANDEMIC.
YES ABSOLUTELY SANDERS THANK
YOU- AS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S JUST NOTED- OUR
INITIAL REQUEST I IMAGINE THIS
WAS THE SECOND AND FINAL
REQUEST OUR INITIAL REQUEST TO
LOOK INTO THIS TO EXPAND OUR
ABILITY TO USE OUR OWN SPACE
BETTER- IT PREDATED THE COBIT
CONDEMNING. AND WHAT THIS
PANDEMIC IS REALLY DONE IS
ALLOW US TO- IN PERHAPS A
LITTLE EARLIER THAN WE WOULD
HAVE OTHERWISE EXPECTED BUT
IT'S ALLOWED US TO. REALLY DO A
LARGE SCALE EXPERIMENT AND
PROVE THAT THIS CAN BE DONE OR
APARTMENT LIKE OURS SO- THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY FEEDING INTO OUR
LONG TERM PLANS- AND YOU KNOW
IF WE'RE IF WE'RE SUCCESSFUL WE
CAN MODEL THE WAY. FOR OTHER
STATE AGENCIES TO REALLY
ULTIMATELY REDUCING OUR OVERALL
PHYSICAL FOOTPRINT. GREAT OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS ITEM
IS- HELD OPEN. AND WILL MOVE
NOW TO ISSUE THIRTEENTH WHICH
IS HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
PROPERTY FUND. A GOODAFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SO MY
NAME IS BRIAN ANNIS I'M THE
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. AND-
ITEM THIRTEEN IS THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROPERTY FIND BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL. AS THE STAFF
AGENDA NOTES THE PROPERTY FUND
IS ESTABLISHED IN STATE LAW FOR
HIGH SPEED RAIL TO DEPOSIT
REVENUES RECEIVED FROM THE
AUTHORITIES OWNERSHIP OF
PROPERTY. STATUE ALSO DIRECTS
EXPENDITURES OF THESE REVENUES
FOR YOU SOME DEVELOPMENT
IMPROVEMENT AND MAINTENANCE OF
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM.
CONSISTENT WITH THE APPROPRIATE
USE OF EACH FUNDING SOURCE THAT
PURCHASED THE PROPERTIES IN THE
FIRST PLACE. WITH HIS PC P. YES
ALREADY REQUEST TO INCREASE THE
ANNUAL BUDGET ACT APPROPRIATION
FROM THIS FIND. FROM SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND TO
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
A PERIOD OF TWO YEARS. AND
AFTER THAT THE ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION WOULD BE REDUCED
TO TWO POINT FIVE MILLION PER
YEAR. THIS REQUEST IS DUE TO
THE FINE BALANCE GROWING TO
ABOUT TEN MILLION DOLLARS. IN
THE AUTHORITY HAVING FUTURE
EXPENSES RELATED TO PROPERTY
ATRE. FOUR MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR. THE AUTHORITY HAS
HISTORICALLY USED THESE FUNDS
FOR COST RELATED TO PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT AND WILL CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE THESE EXPENDITURES.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
ELLIS- FINANCE PLEASE. MATTHEW
MYSTERIO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I'LL JUST NOTE THAT HIGH SPEED
RAIL WILL- DOES HAVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE PROPERTY
MAINTENANCE RELATED COSTS AND
WE BELIEVE THAT USING THE FOR
THE MONIES IN THIS FUND- IS THE
MOST APPROPRIATE OF HIGH SPEED
RAILS FUNDS SOURCES. THANK YOU
LMAO. GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN
BROWN WITH THE L. A. L. BUT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL THE FUND HAS A
SUFFICIENT BALANCE TO HANDLE
THE INCREASED PROPOSED
AUGMENTATION AND THE AUTHORITY
HAS IDENTIFIED PROJECTS WE
THINK ARE REASONABLE FOR A FOR
AT THIS POINT. THANK YOU- I
JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION DOES THE
AUTHORITY. CURRENTLY MANAGE ANY
PROPERTIES OUTSIDE OF THE
INITIAL INITIAL CONSTRUCTION A
SEGMENT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY-
I'M TRYING TO AB WHERE WE'RE
COURSE BUILDING BETWEEN- MADERA
AND POPLAR AVENUE NORTH OF
BAKERSFIELD THAT'S A HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILE SEGMENT I WHEN I
WONDERSTRUCK MAKE URE I
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION I MEAN
THAT SEGMENT SO WE DO HAVE SOME
PARCELS THAT- WERE PURCHASED AS
SAID A FULL PARCEL MEANING
THAT- YOU MAY HAVE ONLY NEEDED
HALF OF THE PARCEL- BUT- WE MAY
OWN A- AT THE LANDOWNER MAY
HAVE ASKED US TO BUY THE FULL
PARCEL SO WE WOULD HAVE SOME.
WHAT WE CALL NON OPERATIONAL
PARCELS THAT ARE JUST OUTSIDE
OUR ALIGNMENT DUE TO THE
PURCHASE OF A FULL PARCEL
OUTSIDE OF THAT HUNDRED NINETY
MILES- THE AUTHORITY DID JACK
HAS WORKED WITH A- HOMELESS
CENTER IN BAKERSFIELD- THEY
WERE IMPACTED BY OUR FUTURE
PROJECT AND WE'RE LOOKING TO
MOVE SO WE DID A PURCHASE AS
SOME LANDEN KNAPP IN
BAKERSFIELD- SO WE WANT IT
NEGATIVELY IMPACT. A HOMELESS
FACILITY- BUT OUTSIDE MY DAY
BAKE. THAT SEGMENT YOU HAVEN'T
BROUGHT OR YOU DON'T MANAGE-
ANY PROPERTIES. YES CORRECT
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OKAY. OF ALL RIGHT
AGAIN THIS IS A FILE ITEM IS
ALL HOLD OPEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH MOVED TO ITEM
FOURTEEN. THIRRING FUNGUS ITEM
ITEM BY JOINT BY OUR- CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER- ATTY NICE
INJURE. IN CASE I GET STUMPED
WITH ANY QUESTIONS WHICH COULD
HAPPEN EASILY OKAY- AS THE
STAFFING GENDA NOTES. PROPERTY
FINE IS THIS SKEWS ME- YEAH THE
AUTHORITY HERE IN IN THE I. T.
AREAS REQUESTING A BUDGET
ADJUSTMENT REDUCE THE
AUTHORITIES IT CONSULTING STAFF
WHICH CURRENTLY PROVIDED YOU
ARE RAIL DELIVERY PARTNER
CONTRACT HOW WE WOULD REDUCE
CONSULTING STAFF BY THE
EQUIVALENT OF TWENTY FIVE POINT
FOR A FULL TIME CONSULTANT
POSITIONS AND REPLACE THEM WITH
SEVENTEEN NEW STATE STAFF
POSITIONS. THIS ADJUSTMENT WILL
RESULT IN A NET SAVINGS OF FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION PER YEAR AS
STATE STAFF WILL BE LESS
EXPENSIVE AND CONSULTANTS. AS
THE STAFF ADJOURNMENT NOTES BY
THIS ACTION IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE NOVEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA STATE PONDER REPORT.
THAT FOUND THE AUTHORITIES
RELIANCE ON CONTRACTORS WAS A
KEY RISK AREA TO THE ON GOING
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM. SO
SENSE THAT AUDIT- WE HAVE BRAD
AT FORWARD A BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS AND FINANCE LETTERS
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
TO CONVERT TECH CONSULTANTS TO
STATE STAFF WHERE APPROPRIATE.
AND THAT THIS WOULD BE THE
THIRD AND FINAL AT B. C. P.
RELATED TO OUR INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AREA. WELL AS LONG
AS IT'S A NET ANNUAL OF
SAVINGS. THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT. OKAY FINANCE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE CONCUR
WITH HIGH SPEED DRILLS PROPOSED.
THANK YOU M. L. A. O. MISTER
BROWN. YES HI BLAME BROWN AND
GET THE L. A. O. WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL
MISTER ANDERSON NOTED IT IS
BOTH CONSISTENT WITH PRIOR
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS TO SHIFT
SOME OF THESE RESOURCES FROM
THE CONTRACTOR TO STATE STAFF
AS WELL AS THE STATE AUDITOR'S
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. WORK OKAY ON
ONE- SHORT QUESTION MR JANICE
IS A- DO YOU THINK THAT YOU
WILL BE RELYING ON IT
CONSULTANTS IN THE FUTURE
MOVING FORWARD. BUT THIS WOULD
COMPLETE OUR TRANSITION- WITH
IT CONSULTANTS IN THE AREA-
THAT ARE SUPPLIED BY OUR RAIL
DELIVERY PARTNER- WE WOULD TO
INVASION A CONTINUATION FOR
HIGHLY SPECIALIZED
APPLICATIONS- WE HAVE SOME-
GEOGRAPHIC INFORMATION SYSTEMS
AND A FEW OTHER SYSTEMS WHERE-
THE SKILL SET NEEDED MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE AND STATE SERVICE SO
WE- WOULD LIKELY CONTINUE TO
CONTRACT OUT FOR THE- THAT TYPE
OF I. T. BUT WHERE IT IS A-
FUNCTION WHERE WE CAN FIND
STATE STAFF. AT THAT WOULD HAVE
THE SKILLS TO PERFORM THE WORK
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRANSITIONING AND- AS WAS NOTED
AS WELL- WE ARE REDUCING THE
NET NUMBER OF RESOURCES HERE
ARE ACTION SONGS CAME IN TO
HELP US STAND OUT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT APPLICATIONS TO
SUPPORT A- A CONSTRUCTION
PROGRAM. AND WE ARE NOT ONLY
SHIFTING FROM STATE STAFF
ASKING ME FROM CONSULTANTS TO
STATE STAFF BUT WE ARE REDUCING
THE NET NUMBER OF RESOURCES WE
WOULD USE GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE
THAT- THIS ITEM IS- HELD OPEN
AND- THANK YOU. WE MOVE ON NOW
TO ISSUE FIFTEENTH. THIS IS THE
C. H. P. RADIO CONSOLE REYES
PLACEMENT PROJECT. I THINK
THAT'S THE. SPEAKING HERE MISS
RIGHT. YES MA'AM GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FELLOW. SO I'M
COMMISSIONER MONTEREY AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
DISCUSS THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL'S BUDGET. I WON ALSO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
HELPING US PREPARE FOR THE
HEARING TODAY. WE HAVE THREE
OPEN BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS
THAT I HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT.
EACH ONE IS CRUCIAL TO OUR
MISSION OF PROVIDING SAFETY
SERVICE AND SECURITY TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I'LL BEGIN WITH
AN OVERVIEW OF EACH B. C. P.
STARTING WITH ISSUE FIFTEEN THE
RADIO CONSOLE REPLACEMENT
PROJECT. AND AS ALWAYS I
WELCOME ANY DISCUSSION OR
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. SO OUR
FIRST RBC P. WHICH IS THE RADIO
CONSOLE REPLACEMENT PROJECT.
THE C. H. P. REQUEST A MULTI
YEAR BUDGET DOCUMENTATION FROM
MOTOR VEHICLE CAL TO ADDRESS
COST INCREASES ASSOCIATED WITH
THE RADIO CONSOLE REPLACEMENT
PROJECT. THE PROJECT WAS
APPROVED IN FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN. THE
RADIO CONSOLE REPLACEMENT WORK
IS BEING COMPLETED BY THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS OR PSE. THE
CURRENT B. C. P. REQUESTED
DOCUMENTATION OF TWO POINT TWO
SEVEN ONE MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWO.
N. AUGMENTATION OF TWO POINT
TWO THREE MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR. TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THE CHP OPERATES
TWENTY FIVE EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATION CENTERS INTO
TRAINING CENTERS. ALL OF OUR
COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS ARE
EQUIPPED WITH RADIO CONSOLE
SYSTEMS WHICH PROVIDE MISSION
CRITICAL VOICE COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN THE CHP DISPATCHERS
FIELD OFFICERS AND R. L. A.
AGENCY PARTNER. THE CHP IS
EXISTING AB TECH RADIO CONSOLES
ARE WELL BEYOND SERVICE LIFE
EXPECTANCY AND ARE
UNSUPPORTABLE. SOME AFTER A
CONSUL SYSTEMS THEIR PURCHASE
OVER TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AGO AND
WERE INSTALLED BETWEEN.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AND TWENTY
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO. AND MOST
OF THEM HAVE BEEN IN SERVICE
FOR WELL OVER TWENTY YEARS. THE
RADIO CONSOLE REPLACEMENT
PROJECT BEGAN WITH THE CHP
DEVELOPING AN EXHAUSTIVE SET OF
SPECIFICATIONS IN COLLABORATION
WITH YES WITH THE PSC.
ENTERTAINER TALK WHAT'S THE
EQUIPMENT VENDOR AWARDED THE
CONTRACT AFTER A COMPETITIVE
BID PROCESS. FOLLOWING THE
SUCCESSFUL CONSUL PILOT PROJECT
C. H. P. NTSE ENDEAVOR TO ROLL
OUT THE NEW INTERTIDAL SYSTEM
STATEWIDE. THE NEW RADIO
CONSOLES ARE INTERCONNECTED
BETWEEN OUR DISPATCH CENTERS TO
ALLOW CHANNEL AND WORK LOAD
SHARING. THIS FUNCTION DOES NOT
EXIST IN OUR ANTIQUATED SYSTEMS
THAT ARE BEING REPLACED. WE
HAVE SEVENTEEN REMAINING
COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS GET
DEPRESSED ELATION. WE WILL BE
INSTALLING HIS NEW SYSTEM AT
OUR GOLDEN GATE COMMUNICATION
SYSTEM WHICH IS OUR SECOND
LARGEST LOCATION IN APRIL OF
THIS YEAR. WE ANTICIPATE
COMPLETION OF THE REMAINING
INSTALLATION OF THE RADIO
CONSOLES IN FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. THE
CRITICAL NEED FOR THE RADIO
CONSOLE REPLACEMENT PROJECT TO
CONTINUE AND RECEIVE ADEQUATE
FUNDING NOT IN NOT BE
UNDERSTATED. C. H. P. CONTINUES
TO EXPERIENCE A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN FAILURES WITH THE
ANTIQUATED SYSTEM. AND WHEN THE
RADIO CONSOLES FAIL CALLS FOR
SERVICE RECEIVED BY THE NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM IN NOT BE
PROPERLY COMMUNICATED TO FEEL
PATROL OFFICERS BY DISPATCHERS.
THIS SCENARIO REQUIRES
ADDITIONAL DISPATCH CENTERS TO
PICK UP THE EXTRA CALL WHY.
ADDITIONALLY A LARGE BENEFIT TO
THIS NEWER SYSTEM IS THE
ENHANCE COMMUNICATIONS WITH OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS. C. H.
B. L. O. U. S. AND CALTRANS ARE
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THE NEW INNER TALK SYSTEMS. THE
CHP HAS ADDED NUMEROUS CALTRANS
CHANNELS- AS SEVERAL
COMMUNICATION CENTER IS ALSO
IMPROVED RADIO COMMUNICATIONS
DURING EMERGENCY INCIDENTS.
THIS UNIFORMITY AND EQUIPMENT
STANDARDIZATION BETWEEN
AGENCIES ELEVATE THE CHP'S
ABILITY TO PROVIDE MORE
EFFICIENT SUPPORT DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DURING DAY TO
DAY OPERATIONS. SO THANK YOU
FOR PROVIDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE OUR
RADIO CONSOLE REPLACEMENT
PROJECT BCP AND ALL STAND BY IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THE- FIRM IT'S C. OF FINANCE
PLEASE THANK YOU MYSTERY. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SURE
KATHY MACLEOD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WE CAN CURVE WITH THE
STAFF- RECOMMENDATION AND WE
NOTE THAT THE AND THE NBA IS
THE MAJOR CONCERN IN THAT. WE
MONITOR THE MBA FUND CONDITION
WHILE WERE. GOING THROUGH THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS AND
THAT THERE IS AN ADEQUATE FUND
BALANCE TO FUND THIS ALSO THREE.
OKAY THANK YOU. OF THE L. A-
PLEASE. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- WE DO NOT HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
WE FIND THAT THE REQUEST IS
REASONABLE GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE
OF RADIO CONSOLES AND PUBLIC
SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE- WE NOTE
THAT THE REQUEST IS A ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION SO THERE IS NOW
ONGOING IMPACT TO THAT MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNT. OKAY THANK YOU I
JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION-
COMMISSIONER- WITH REGARDS TO
THE- PROJECT INCREASES A- HOW
MUCH OF THAT COULD BE PLANNED
AND OVER YOU KNOW WHAT PERIOD
OF TIME SO THAT IT DOESN'T
BECOME AN UNEXPECTED COST. I'M
TRYING I'M CAN YOU REPEAT THE
QUESTION AGAIN MA'AM I'M SORRY
YEAH THAT'S OKAY- I'M JUST
LOOKING THAT IT- IT WAS THIS-
AN UNEXPECTED COST OR SOMETHING
THAT WAS PLANNED OR JUST
LOOKING TO THE FUTURE HOW YOU
WOULD HANDLE IN THE FUTURE.
POLICY WE ALL AGREE WITH YOU
YOU NEED TO UPDATE WHEN YOU
NEED TO UPDATE. YES
UNFORTUNATELY THERE WERE-
SEVERAL TECHNICAL PROBLEMS THAT
CAME UP STATEWIDE WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE SO YES- ALTHOUGH
MAJORITY OF THIS PLAN THERE
WERE SOME THINGS THAT CAME UP.
AFTER THE INITIAL- PROJECT
ROLLOUT THAT DID REQUIRED SOME
AUGMENTATION WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
HERE TODAY BUT YES WE ARE. I
FEEL LIKE MOVE FORWARD WE WILL
BE FINE. OKAY ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS NO. OF OKAY I WITH
THIS BILL WILL MOVE ON THAT'S
TO BE HELD OPEN A COMMISSIONER
YOU WANT TO MOVE ON TO. ISSUE
SIXTEEN PORTABLE RADIOS
REPLACING A PORTABLE RADIOS.
YES MADAM CHAIR. ITSELF FOR THE
REPLACEMENT OF PORTABLE RADIOS
THE CHP REQUEST A PERMANENT
AUGMENTATION EIGHT POINT SIX
ZERO FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE
CAL. REPLACE PORTABLE RADIOS
AND ACCESSORIES THAT HAVE
EXCEEDED THEIR LIFE EXPECTANCY.
ARE OUT OF WARRANTY OR
UNSERVICEABLE. THE PORTABLE
RADIO IS VITAL TO THE CHP'S
MISSION AND IS A CRITICAL LINK
BETWEEN OFFICERS IN THE FIELD
DISPATCHERS AND OUR ALLY
REGENCY PARK. IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN C. H. BE PURCHASED
EIGHT THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE MOTOROLA AT
EXPORTABLE MODE BAND RADIO. AS
WELL AS SUFFICIENT ACCESSORIES
TO DEPLOY TWO UNIFORMED STAFF.
THE MOTOROLA A. P. X. AND YOUR
RADIO FOR US HOWEVER THE
PORTABLE RADIOS HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYED IN THE FIELD SINCE
EARLY TWENTY FIFTEEN AND ARE
STARTING TO SHOW SIGNS OF WEAR
DUE TO THEIR TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
USE. IN A WIDE VARIETY OF
OPERATIONAL ENVIRONMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE CHP'S EXPECTS
EXISTING STOCK OF ACCESSORIES
SUCH AS BATTERIES ANTENNAS IN
THE PALE MICROPHONES ARE
INSUFFICIENT TO FULLY SUPPORT
CONTINUING SERVICE ME. APPROACH
THIS PROPOSAL IS SIX TO REPLACE
ONE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY PORTABLE RADIOS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS. THIS FIGURE
EQUATES TO A YEARLY REPLACEMENT
OF APPROXIMATELY 20% OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S INITIAL INVENTORY.
WITH THIS A PRO FINDING THE C.
H. P. SIX SEEKS TO ESTABLISH A
FIVE YEAR REPLACEMENT STRATEGY
TO BE ME BOTH AS A DENTAL AN
ONGOING REPLACEMENT NEEDS. AS
WELL AS HAVING A READILY
AVAILABLE REPLACEMENT SUPPLY.
THE PROCUREMENT OF THE PORTABLE
RADIOS AND ACCESSORIES
LEVERAGES THE POWER OF THE
WHOLESALE PURCHASING. A. Y.
CONTRACTING ELIMINATES THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
INDIVIDUAL EMERGENCY PURCHASES.
C. H. PEOPLE PRIORITIZE THE
FIRST REPLACEMENTS GOING TO THE
FIELD OFFICES THAT HAVE RADIO
SHORTAGES DUE TO DAMAGED AWAY
HURT AND THEN THE FEEL STAFF IN
PORT WILL BE USED TO DETERMINE
THE PRIORITY AFTER THAT. IS
CHP'S TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SECTION RECEIVES REQUESTS FOR
DIGITAL RADIOS FROM THE FIELD
DIVISIONS WEEKLY. I WOULD LIKE
TO NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
INTENDS TO CONTINUE WITH THE
MOTOROLA ATRIX PRODUCTS WELL
INTO THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE. AS
A COST EFFICIENT RADIO SOLUTION
MOTOROLA'S PRICING IS
COMPARABLE TO OTHER VENDORS BUT
HAVE FEATURES SUCH AS THE TRI
BAND WIFI AND BLUETOOTH MEET
OUR CURRENT OPERATIONAL NEEDS.
ADDITIONALLY AS OF RIGHT NOW
ONLY MOTOROLA PROVIDES THE
ABILITY TO UPDATE RADIOS FROM
THE CHP WIFI NETWORK AS OPPOSED
TO COLLECTING AND UPDATING THE
RADIOS MANUAL. SO THE GREATEST
BENEFIT OF THE MALL ROAD IS
EIGHTY X. IS INTEROPERABLE OF
THE MAJORITY OF THE STATE
COUNTY AND LOCAL AGENCIES THAT
WE WORK ALONGSIDE OPERATE ON
MODI. ON MULTIPLE RADIO BANDS
MOTOROLA ATX RADIOS ASSISTED
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL ALLIED AGENCY
PARTNERS. DURING THE MERGER
SEES AND NATURAL DISASTERS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK ON THE CAP'S PORTABLE
RADIO REPLACEMENT BCT. AND I
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT WAS VERY
THOROUGH. OF I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS MEMBERS. NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ALRIGHT THAT I ITEM
IS- ON HOLD AND- FROM SORRY.
FINANCE I WAS SKIPPING YOU. WE
JUST NOTE THE RADIOS ARE
FUNDAMENTAL TO THE MISSION OF
THE CHP BEFORE THE OFFICERS AND
THE PUBLIC. THANK YOU. MADAME
LA- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SO WE DO NOT HAVE TO CONCERNS
OF THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WE
FIND THAT THE REQUEST IS
REASONABLE GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE
OF PORTABLE RADIOS AND
COMMUNICATION WITHIN CHP AND
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AT THE REQUEST WILL HAVE AN
ONGOING IMPACT ON THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT BAD GIVEN THAT
PORTABLE RADIOS LIKE ANY OTHER
EIGHTY COMMITTEES HAVE A USEFUL
LIFE REGULAR REPLACEMENT SUCH
EQUIPMENT SEEMS WARRANTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND WILL
MOVE TO OUR LAST ITEM-
COMMISSIONER THIS IS THE ISSUE
SEVENTEEN THE WIRELESS IN CAR
CAMERA SYSTEM MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS. YES MADAM CHAIR SO
FOR THE FINAL ITEM. S. C. H. P.
REQUEST A PERMANENT
AUGMENTATION OF FOURTEEN POINT
TWO TWO MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE MOTOR VEHICLE COUNTS FOR
ONGOING MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATION OF THE WIRELESS IN
CAR CAMERA SYSTEM. ALSO KNOWN
AS WIRELESS MOBILE VIDEO AND
AUDIO RECORDING SYSTEM FOR M.
W. EMBARKS. THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AUTHORIZED
TWELVE POSITIONS AND FIFTY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS A THREE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CHP'S
WIRELESS IN CAR CAMERA SYSTEM.
THIS CURRENT BCG IS INTENDED TO
FIND THE ONGOING MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATION OF THE ALREADY
APPROVED W. IN BARS AS WELL AS
COVER THE ONGOING COSTS OF THE
TWELVE PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
POSITIONS. THE W. HAVE OURS
REPLACES OUR CURRENT DVD IN CAR
CAMERA SYSTEM WITH A WIRELESS
IN CAR CAMERA SYSTEM. THIS
ELIMINATES THE ENTITY IN THE
ADEQUATE USE OF COST THE USE
AND COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH DVD
RECORDINGS AND REPRODUCTION.
THE W. HAVE OURS ALLOWS FOR
HIGHER QUALITY RECORDINGS AND
AUTOMATIC WIRELESS DATA
TRANSFER USING CELLULAR MODEMS
AND WIFI CONNECTED. A NICE
BRIGHT BY PRODUCTS OF OUR W.
EMBARRASSED THAT IT ALSO HAS
THE ABILITY TO INTEGRATE WITH
BODY WORN CAMERA SYSTEMS IN THE
FUTURE. WE'RE ALL OUT OF PHASE
ONE FOR W. OF OURS BEGAN ON
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY OCTOBER
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. AND IS
ANTICIPATED TO BE COMPLETED IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THIS PHASE INCLUDED WIRING
ANTENNA WORK. AT THE END
TECHNOLOGY OP ED TECHNOLOGY
PREPARATION SUCH AS THE SERVER
INSTALLATION. ROLL OUT OF PHASE
TWO WHICH INCLUDES HARDWARE
INSTALLATION CONTROL VEHICLE
FITTING AND MODEM INSTALLATION
IS ANTICIPATED TO BE COMPLETED
BY NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. NEW VEHICLE BILLS WILL RUN
PARALLEL WITH A ROLLOUT PHASE
TWO AND IS ANTICIPATED TO BE
COMPLETED BY NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS WELL.
AND IT IS OUR INTENT TO EQUIP
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED NEW VEHICLES WITH W. M.
BARS. ULTIMATELY THIS BASICALLY
ALLOWED A C. H. P. TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. AND IT HAS
COMMUNITY RELATIONS BY
CONTINUING TO FIND OUR
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED WIRELESS IN
CAR CAMERA SYSTEM. AND THANK
YOU MEDICARE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK ABOUT OUR WIRELESS IN
PART NUMBER SYSTEM THESE THESE.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER- OF
FINANCE PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
ISSUES AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU-
MA'AM LOL. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE DO NOT HAVE CONCERNED
TO THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WE
FIND THAT THE PROPOSAL IS
REASONABLE GIVEN THE POTENTIAL
OF IN CAR CAMERA SYSTEMS TO
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WITHIN THE CHP-
THE REQUEST WILL HAVE AN
ONGOING IMPACT ON THE MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNT THEY GIVEN THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROPER INITIATION
DOCUMENTATION OF DATA FROM
THESE IN CAR CAMERA SYSTEMS THE
ONGOING COSTS TO MAINTAIN
CONSISTENCY IN. JUSTIFIED GREAT.
OKAY THANK YOU COMMISSIONER
AND- PLEASE THE KNOW THAT WE
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH WHAT THE
OFFICERS IN THE STAFF AND
EVERYONE WHO WORKS FOR THE C.
H. P. APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
WORK AND THE WAY YOU TAKE CARE
OF US. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND PLEASE FORGIVE ME I FORGOT
TO INTRODUCE THAT GENTLEMAN TO
MY RIGHT WHICH IS OURS SHE-
MIKE ALVAREZ WAS OVER OUR
OFFICE IS SPECIAL
REPRESENTATIVES I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE AT A RECORD
AND I KNOW THAT HE WAS HERE
WITH E. TOO OKAY BUT THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US THANK YES THANK
YOU MISTER ALBERS WERE BEING
HERE AS WELL OKAY THAT ITEM IS
ALSO ON HOLD- THAT'S THE END OF
OUR ISSUES. YEAH BUT. WE NOW
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. CAN
LET'S SEE IF I GET THIS RIGHT-
WE'RE NOW WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
ITEMS RELATED TO PART B. OF THE
AGENDA. PART B. AS A REMINDER
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING. UP
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE LIMITS OUGHT TIME
LIMITS ON THE TESTIMONY TODAY
I'M GOING TO ASK EACH MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENT.
TO KEEP THEIR REMARKS WITHIN
ONE MINUTE- NOW LET'S BEGIN
WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEN NONE OF OUR
ANY WITNESSES AND ROOM. TWELVE
THREE NONE OF. NO WILL MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE PLUS
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN.
ABSOLUTELY IF YOU LIKE TO MAKE
A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
OUR FIRST CONFIRMATION TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MADAM CHAIR
INDICATORS MICHAEL THAT COULD
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION MY COMMENTS
ARE SUBJECT TO ITEM NUMBER
NINE. DEVELOPMENT I WANT TO
START OFF I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR RECOGNIZING
THAT- FIVE MILLION CHALLENGES
THAT TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE FACED
WITH. I HAVE TO BE A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL FOR BOTH. IF YOU
THAT THE STATURE RELIEF
MEASURES. FOR INDUSTRY AND
WE'RE STILL IN THE PROCESS TO
REVIEW EACH OF THESE PLEASE
MEASURES BUT I WOULD SIGNAL
THAT THE ALIGN CLOSELY WITH
MAKERS WE PURSUED PURSUED IN
PREVIOUS YEARS ALIGN WELL WITH
OUR CURRENT POLICY PRIORITIES.
NO MATTER IF YOU GET ASK REALLY
ABOUT THE APPROPRIATE LENGTH OF
THE POLITICAL OF THESE RELIEF
MEASURES AND I WOULD ONLY NOTE
THAT CONGRESS IS CURRENTLY
WORKING ON EMERGENCY RELIEF TO
SUPPORT TRANSIT AGENCIES FOR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE RECOGNIZING
THAT BUDGET SHORTFALLS LIKE THE
LAST. RAP YEAH HI AND AS SUCH
WE WOULDN'T BREAK UP THAT MANY
EVALUATE EXTENDING THE DURATION
OF THE RELIEF ARTWORK CRITICAL
YEAR TWENTY THREE OR AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO IT CONTINUE CAN
GAUGE WITH YOU AND THE
ADMINISTRATION THE COMING WEEK.
THE DISCUSS USUALLY MEASURES
FURTHER- AND AGAIN JUST WANT TO
THANK. GOODNESS RATIONS ARE
MOVING THESE UNLESS RESTORED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. NOW MOST WATER. UNDER NO
FURTHER Q. OKAY. BUT MODERATE
CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
ONCE AGAIN JUST TO BE SURE WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. SHE ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
THE PRESS ONE ZERO AT TIMES.
WE
HAVE NO ONE TO YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF. NOW WILL MOVE
TO VOTE AND- WILL TAKE UP THE
OF VOTES ON THE BOAT ONLY
CALENDAR ISSUES ONE THROUGH
SEVEN- IS THERE STILL. I'M
SORRY OKAY. OKAY WAIT FOR
SENATOR WILL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WILK. NUMBER REQUEST IT
WAS BUT IT WAS LATE KNOW WHAT
WERE WAITING OKAY SO. WITHOUT A
HIGH ISSUE TO OKAY. OKAY SO-
WITH C. OKAY SO LET'S TAKE THAT
ONE UP FIRST THEN- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION OF THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR ISSUE. TO THE MOVES
OKAY SENATOR WILK. THE SO LET'S
VOTE NOW. ISSUE TO MOTIONS
APPROVED BUDGETED DORADO. YES
WILK NO CORTESE ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN RIGHT. NINE THREE ONE
OKAY THE LOTUS THREE TO ONE. OF
THE PAST THREE SHOULD ISSUE TO
US NOW THAT WE HAVE THE
REMAINDER OF THE ISSUES WE NEED
A VOTE A MOTION FOR VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR ISSUES ONE. AND THREE
TO SEVEN. SO MOVED. OKAY. SO
THAT MOTION OKAY WE TAKE THE
VOTE ISSUES ONE AND THREE
THIRTY SEVEN MOTIONS APPROVE IS
BUDGETED DORADO. I'D RATHER AYE
WILK ALL RIGHT WILK HI CORTESE
FOR DAISY AYE NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE.
FOUR ZERO OKAY SO THAT VOTE IS
DONE. THAT'S IT SO LET ME JUST
SEND WITH THE OFFICIAL AND THE
IN THANK YOU TO ALL HE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE KNOW YOU'RE
OUT THERE IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE. YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE FACIAL HEARING
RECORDS THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE IS A JOURNEY
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
MA'AM. AND THANK YOU.